[Laughter]
well hey everybody
hopefully everybody has recovered from
their drinking last night because it was
saint patrick's day
we only had one drink though i'm
drinking right now what [ __ ] up well
came back from biker barn he's already
he's been drinking all day drinking all
day
it's all good though i show up i was
just talking to pookie and she looked at
me
because i grabbed i grabbed that [ __ ]
thing right there i grabbed and i was
like what are you yelling at she's
yelling at you daddy it didn't have
anything to do with her she's like she's
like everything has to do it's a poopy
centric world
yeah everything has to do with it i grab
the [ __ ] little table and take it
away she's like
i'm like
for what so what i took it i don't know
you're altering my environment in a way
that i don't appreciate the truth
although right before we started
streaming i was watching a video of
people that had put uh pictures up that
of their cats being jerks yeah and
some of the stuff that people's cats get
into
is pretty crazy like they're some of
them are pretty destructive pookie is
not really all that destructive she does
get into stuff
but
she's never really broken anything she's
a rock and roll pookie coo
i told her well because he mentioned
that song just now because he was
watching a video about it and i said
every time i hear a song i just uh
immediately try to fit pookie's name in
it somehow so i can sing it to her i
don't know if she appreciates it or not
she seems to tolerate it she doesn't
like run away or she just looks at you
you sing to her and she just looks at
you like
we were watching you know it's funny we
were watching um
dan bell's live stream from last
saturday because he doesn't i don't know
if you guys know but he does a live
stream every saturday night where he
drives around and he's been doing a
thing the last couple months where one
of his patrons he does a drawing and if
one of his patrons can get to baltimore
where he lives um he'll take them with
him so he does like a two or three like
drive around baltimore they do ghost
hunting they do all kind of stuff
so i was watching that one and like
one of dan's dogs he was still like in
his apartment
you s if he sings to the dog the dog
like flops over and like lays down
that's the damnest thing i ever saw yeah
to get the dog to stop
just starts singing the dog and then he
surrenders yeah
he went like that he like flopped over
i'm like holy [ __ ] yeah and then dad
like comes back in the car and he's like
laughing his ass off i'm like that is
pretty funny though like if you want the
dog to stop all you gotta do is start
singing
the dog flowers over i don't know like
pookie just kind of
she just puts up with it i don't think
she cares one way or the other i think
she just likes the attention
but uh you know
dj meeting said oh that's right it was
amateur hour yesterday exactly
that's why
we don't go out on st patrick's day yeah
patty saint patty's day
because that's kind of all
you know
yeah that's kind of all it's kind of
like new year's eve although i will
admit we did go out new year's eve this
year we don't usually uh we just went to
mannequins and that was actually it was
actually really fun but yeah that's the
problem you get like all these people
that
you know that don't really drink all
that much like all the year and then
they decide they're gonna binge drink or
day drink like for the first time ever
and uh you know they can't handle it so
people are like laying around puking in
the streets and whatnot
so it doesn't sound like a good time so
we're gonna like drink today we had one
drink last night while we were watching
movies
and that's about it what the [ __ ] do we
even what did we watch last night i
don't remember uh a bunch of stuff we
weren't we weren't drunk we were i just
had one drink what do we do
i don't remember what it was we saw um
it was um
[ __ ]
it just totally went out of my head
isn't that doesn't matter it doesn't
matter i mean it does kind of oh no no i
remember because it was something i
wanted to talk about on here uh it's
that documentary on shutter about alien
oh that's right it's called memory
and it's kind of about it was kind of
cool actually they didn't it wasn't so
much about the making of the movie it
was kind of
all the different uh idea threads that
kind of like
came together with dan o'bannon and the
writer and like ridley scott and and uh
you know and uh
you know
it was mostly good it was i can't
remember the like h.r giger thank you
yeah jesus christ yeah um thank you
brain for coughing that up but yeah it
was kind of like where the i'd like the
mythology behind it like where the ideas
for it came from like all the sci-fi
movies
that uh that dan o'bannon had watched in
the 50s and like where he got the ideas
for stuff and all that so it's actually
really good if you want to watch it
but um
yeah i thought it was good but you know
some of it was [ __ ] though
they had some girl jumping in saying
that [ __ ] alien was a result of uh of
the guilt of misogyny and all this
[ __ ] that's not really what she was
saying that's kind of what she was
saying that's not really what she was
saying
well that's how i took it it was
[ __ ] though because it had nothing
to do with that those dudes were just
making up something like yeah it was a
it was a [ __ ] alien kind of like a
wasp
it there wasn't a deeper meaning to it
really but the thing about it though is
when you create a piece of art and send
it out into the world yeah usually an
artist has you know whatever their
intention is whether it's
conscious or unconscious
but then uh when you when it goes out
into the world and other people
consume it uh those people bring their
own sets of experiences and their own
sets of
unconscious uh biases fantasies whatever
so they're gonna take what they want to
take out of it too so i kind of feel
like
you know yeah there's some argument to
be made that um
to an extent like
obviously some things are like textual
subtextual like the artist intended that
but sometimes
if there's like a reading of it that has
to do with like one person's or one like
particular group of people's like uh
perceptions i don't think that's
necessarily invalid because if that many
people like saw that in there
then obviously that is speaking to them
so like i said you know art is
it's subjective you can kind of like
read whatever you wanted to it
my take on it was it was my dad's
generation that made that movie in the
70s and late 70s
they weren't thinking along that lines
it was it was a lot simpler than that
other people later on want to read into
it but it didn't have anything to do
with misogyny no
well it i don't know i don't know if i'd
go that far but it definitely did have
something to do with um
male rape and male impregnation well
they said that which like i said was
kind of like
and that wasn't a new thing either
because i've seen some movies i saw a
movie from the 1950s i think it was the
1950s or very early 1960s it was on mst
called night of the blood beast yeah and
it was just like this shitty might have
been roger corman now that i'm thinking
about it it's a whole black and white
movie and it's this dude and he goes up
uh to space wherever the hell i don't
remember where he goes and he comes back
and he's in the capsule like the capsule
crashes
and then they haul his body they think
he's dead he is dead so they haul him
out there and then they put him in this
thing and uh he a couple days later he
wakes up
and he seems okay but everyone's just
kind of like i don't know you're acting
like a little bit weird and then there's
like a monster and then they find out
that this guy has been impregnated by
this monster
so there's they do like a little
fluoroscope type situation and they look
and there's like all these little party
shrimp in his stomach
in his womb parties it is man womb party
well that's what they look like i'm
pretty sure that they that they use well
they did it on mst and then they did
like uh they did a gag where they just
like took all these little shrimp and
like taped them onto this like tv like
so it looked like somebody was like
pregnant it was a rape monster yeah back
in the day that's it yeah it's a raid
monster well yeah because it's like
going in their mouth and it's like
coming you know coming out their [ __ ]
butt chest clothes but they got that
from the [ __ ] wasps and wasps are
rape monsters
you're you're you're a worm minding your
own business inside of some wood doing
some wormy [ __ ] and then the thing comes
gets you and then you're pregnant and
then you give birth to these [ __ ]
things and you give birth to things that
didn't like you and they did it over
again that's what that's what that's all
it is it's not they kind of showed and
actually a deeper meaning too in this
documentary they actually did show a
rave monster one of the like a
caterpillar that had been uh like
impregnated by one of these parasitic
wasps yeah and yeah they showed it like
in you know in fast motion it was like
like all these wasps i was like holy
[ __ ] that's what it looks like yeah
there's like eating them from inside
right you know what i mean
but
which the whole idea was [ __ ] it was
about being terrified
yeah and that and uh
and i even noticed it as a kid
is that uh
there was an element of like corporate
classism going on
the working people
[ __ ] were kind of smarter about what
was going on like let's get the [ __ ] out
of here just freeze him why don't you
just freeze him let's get the [ __ ] out
well which i could which would have been
better for them a lot of people because
you're the ones that actually have to
deal with [ __ ] like on the ground right
uh you know and people that are in
management or higher up in the in the on
the totem pole like often are not
dealing with the situation so they don't
really know what's going on yeah i grew
up i grew up in that world and [ __ ]
so i immediately recognized it you know
my dad was also in dealing with that
world out in california in the [ __ ]
water pollution control system
the guys on the ground [ __ ]
understood what was going on the dudes
above them in the officer ranks
had to justify their existence by using
[ __ ]
better vocabulary that's really all it
was it was kind of [ __ ] because
the [ __ ] the working guy is [ __ ]
what was his name [ __ ] uh oh [ __ ] i
forgot the two dudes names
lambert and [ __ ] no lambert was the
was the chick was the the other two the
white dude and the black dude [ __ ]
who were just like yeah yeah was harry
dean stanton was yeah but i don't
remember her name is the characters
they were like look let's just get out
of here
you know why don't you just freeze like
this is above our pace yeah and [ __ ]
you know which it totally was you know
stop [ __ ] with him just freeze him
let's get the [ __ ] out of here
and uh something's not right with this
guy you know
and they were right about it really
it was the officers that were [ __ ] up
letting they let the infection in and
they were trying to look at stuff and
it was all [ __ ] you know well the
i mean that
oh the damn the [ __ ] the ghostly yeah
the ghostly [ __ ] is gone well ash let
the yeah let them in right like even
though ripley was like absolutely not
right ash let them in right
that was his fault yeah that chick was
going like well he's a misogynistic
robot he was he was [ __ ]
rep he was [ __ ]
programmed to do that
that's not how i saw it
well the thing is though it is the
company
well yeah but it is very frustrating
particularly as rip as ripley even
though she was not necessarily written
but it's because she's a woman and her
being in charge and she's just like hey
don't let them in that's protocol and
then just being overridden and
everybody's like oh we don't care what
you say like i get it i get where she
was coming from yeah because you do kind
of feel like that as a woman and you're
not a woman so you wouldn't know but you
do kind of feel like your [ __ ] gets like
overridden that didn't have anything to
do with her being a woman though well no
i'm just saying that yeah somebody like
he like it was the company but i could
see how you would think that because the
character was she would have been
overridden even if she was a man yeah
the company was sent the [ __ ] ship
out there to go get it that's why he was
on there
remember because
he he that's that was his first voyage
they had
replaced the normal science officer with
that robot yeah and they didn't nobody
knew it nobody knew what the hell was
going on they were out there to go get
that thing they just didn't know
really what it was it was about the evil
of corporations and the people that
caught them yeah that's what granthars
was saying i always figured alien was
about one corporate greed and to the
dangers of biological weapons yeah that
too
um dj maniac oh if no one knew that the
design of the xenomorph and its mythos
was an allegory for male rape do i have
a story for you
um yeah there's a wasp one of the things
that's for rapists one of the things
that i didn't realize was that the chess
burster little monster which kind of
looks like a penis
um
was actually taken almost completely
like from a painting by francis bacon
which like i said i hadn't really made
that connection because i really like
francis bacon's artwork
but i had never like made that
connection between
that but if you see the painting i'm
like oh my god that looks that looks
almost exactly like like the chest
burster little guy
one a good thing about this program is
it pointed out that this that this um
that this [ __ ] life cycle this
reproductive cycle about there being a
host and a bee that comes along and
stings it which lays the egg which
[ __ ] comes out of the host which
makes a [ __ ] bee that stings the host
and it makes lazy a that that
that particular
reproductive life cycle is the most
popular reproductive life cycle on the
planet
there are yeah there's there are more
pairs didn't there's more of those than
anything then i think you're right i
mean i'd have to look it up but they did
mention is that there are actually more
species of parasitic wasps on earth than
any other that's what they're kind of
species but i don't really know if
that's true or not that's that's like
the best that's one of the more common
life cycle maps
so you know but the thing is is that
it's happening to
it's happening to [ __ ] um
uh [ __ ]
not not worms they come [ __ ] uh
caterpillars it's happening to
caterpillars so you don't notice it
but you would notice it if you were a
caterpillar wouldn't you
you'd be like what the [ __ ] yeah right
sure that wouldn't be a real pleasant
way to go so they can still feel pain
and stuff right so that's that's what
they're talking about dj maniac says
there's dicks everywhere an alien yeah
yeah dicks yeah there are dicks
everywhere dicks did it is what went
into you well h.r giger i mean his
artwork is very explicitly sexual it's
all sexual yeah um and monsters and i
kind of feel like the original
production company that's why they
didn't really want to go with that
they're like absolutely not we're not
like having that dudes like [ __ ]
artwork because it's you know charity
you know what i mean and it's like
perverted
and this was like back in the 70s you
know so they were just kind of like what
the [ __ ] even is that because nobody was
doing any artwork remotely like that
back then it's all like these
weird-looking corpses with [ __ ]
fantastic asses and [ __ ]
all this weird it's like weird like
biomechanical yeah sure booty monsters
but they you know it so it was kind of
like they had hr gigar on and they
talked about this on the show a little
bit and then like he did a couple
drawings and then the producers were
like no absolutely not that's too weird
and so he got kicked off but then when
ridley scott came on
um he was like he saw the paintings and
he's like oh yeah we're doing that yeah
so he was able to like convince him
uh so and it's funny to think of that
because like alien without h.r giger
it just would it probably would have
still been good but it i don't think it
would have been this would happen
because that like is so distinctive i
mean
just
somebody asked uh let me see i just saw
it up here tyler the guy said
uh
anyone like alien more than aliens i
feel like aliens is the more popular one
uh i do i like alien more than aliens i
love aliens they're both good they're
both good but they're both different uh
genres
and aliens is more like an action movie
like a sci-fi action and i feel like
alien is more a straight-up horror movie
yeah not even it's marginally sci-fi but
i think it's like more a horror movie so
i'm more into that i like that more
creeping dread type uh type thing now
graham said that ash is a replica he
wasn't a replicant he was he was a robot
replicants were genetically engineered
human beings that were
meant to replace robots
and
if you go and look at prometheus
there's both robots and replicants
like um
um
what's it uh [ __ ] tyrell's daughter
one played by
charlie charlie yeah
she's a replica
um but david's the [ __ ] robot
and if you get the if you get the uh
the blu-ray
on the ex on the extended and expanded
extra [ __ ] that's in there
it'll talk about tyrell
waylon knew tyrell
and thought that the [ __ ] replicant
thing
he said the replicant thing literally
blew up in his face
that's not how you want to go you want
to go with robots but there are certain
things that replicants were good at
so
that's why the the the was the name miss
bishop
miss bishop [ __ ] the captain to prove
that she wasn't a robot yeah i remember
that thing she was a she was a replicant
though
which was kind of like a robot made out
of [ __ ]
parts
biologically
engineered parts
and um
it all makes sense when you look at it
from the point of view of an oligarch
oligarchs
their power was built on the back of a
working class and slaves you know when
you go back further back in time
they make money on people
but people are not people have their own
nature they're not very obedient
so it's better if they were to replace
these people with robots or things like
replicants or genetically engineered
people
that way they can they can create them
and uh those people are obedient and you
can create their you can control their
nature
you can hack them
kind of like oh what oh what's his name
saying in the wef
so these movies are are true you know i
mean they're the [ __ ] they know what
they're talking about
an oligarch would rather have a person
that they could create so they could be
godlike
like uh that's why all that shit's kind
of like pharaoh you know i mean with the
pyramids and everything back in l.a the
tyrell corporation
tyrell was kind of like a pharaoh
uh
which is a god man a man who is a god
creating
people it's kind of like how an oligarch
would really like to be especially like
a [ __ ] a real high-tech oligarch so
really scott knew exactly what he was
talking about it it's true it's just
it's art you know it
it's a guy who's making an artistic
movie and trying to tell you something
um now some people didn't like
prometheus or alien alien 2 or what was
the alien 4 what was the name of the one
the one after prometheus alien covenant
alien covenant that's what it was called
a lot of people didn't like them i liked
them
uh they had problems
uh
prometheus was not [ __ ] executed
correctly a lot of [ __ ] got edited out
of it
and then alien covenant they really
edited a lot out of that but it was
close to what the original concept was
the original concept was more closer to
to like
you know near near near abu what's
called nirabil and the [ __ ]
uh the anunnaki that's what they're
talking about
dj maniac says alien without h.r giger
equals darkstar
they did actually talk quite a bit about
darkstar in this well not quite a bit
but like they did kind of because dan
o'bannon obviously was uh you know
worked on that too
um you know the one where the alien was
a beach ball yeah so there was that also
he also brings up something that i had
actually kind of forgotten about dead
kennedy's in a [ __ ] ton of trouble
because they had a geeker painting in
the franken-christ album as an insert i
remember that
didn't they get hauled into court for
like obscenity charges which is crazy
like if you i think they did and if you
see
the painting that they used inside
it's not
like i said it's like biomechanics it's
got like dicks and stuff but it's like
are we saying that like a a part of that
half of like all humans on earth have
just showing that
is pornographic that is ridiculous
it's a dick yeah half the people on
earth have them
it's fine
it's like
i don't know it's just like really funny
but yeah it was the 80s so
but yeah i do remember that happening
[ __ ] jelly biafra was
quite articulate about how uh stupid
that was you know just saying
uh let's see
what's up t yeah she said she couldn't
uh come on wednesday but yeah she showed
up this evening she said she's going to
see the new uh ty west movie x which
i've been hearing a lot of good uh buzz
about that so i might have to go like uh
check that out i've liked all these
other movies so i wonder if it's police
i wonder if it's playing here at least t
saw beverly hills cop
oracle's waving at us what's up oracle
hey
yeah
yeah dj manic says and the case got
dismissed it's why we have the parental
advisory sticker on the records now yep
that's right yeah jelly be offered did a
double live spoken word about it i have
it on vinyl of course yeah he did a lot
of spoken word back in the day
uh waves at pookie in beijing too
yeah i don't know downstairs i think
well i don't know pookie was in here a
minute ago but i don't know where she
went she got mad she was like you guys
aren't paying enough attention to me so
i'm outta here i'm just i'm gonna go
down to like far around and do something
else
let's see uh yeah banana in the tailpipe
somebody says
yeah but yeah so if you have shutter
it's like it's a good documentary it's
totally worth watching
um like i said i like that it didn't
focus
it focused a little bit like on the
making of the movie but it wasn't really
a making up it was more like
a conceptual documentary in the sense
that this is where
all the tendrils uh came from like to
that contributed to the idea of this
movie and like where all this stuff you
know like where all the stuff originated
from like other movies other mythology
stuff like that so i thought that was
like really uh a good angle to come at
it from
um tyler guy jello biafra for sounding
off at tipper goran oprah was so so damn
satisfying oh yeah i remember that that
was a long time ago though it was yeah
yeah i mean yeah we grew up during that
time and it's just
i mean even then i was like still a
teenager and i was just kind of like
this [ __ ] is like [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't know why i'm [ __ ] you
know you all right how much did you
drink today
i had four before i showed up
four or five he left
he left people were buying me drinks 12
was it 12 30 uh yeah somewhere around it
was like a little bit past noon or
somewhere like somewhere between 12 30
came back four seconds and then he came
back about like quarter past four yeah
so he was at the biker bar all the time
were you
like riding around the bike first and
then that was only about 30 minutes 40
minutes and then i [ __ ] went to the
bar oh okay so he's been at the bar
drinking about fourth bad about two and
a half hours three hours because you
seem like a little yeah they bought me a
bunch of [ __ ] i show up [ __ ] start
bobby hey and they start buying me stuff
i don't care
i don't care i don't care i do what i
want yeah free beer yeah
no no do they oh they have actually they
have actual alcohol yeah they buy me
tequila okay that's oh [ __ ]
shots of tequila should you really
should you really be riding a motorcycle
around yeah on all that tequila of
course you should yeah i don't i don't
think you should of course it's just up
the street but of course it's so easy to
ride it's easy
yeah well no it's easier to ride than it
is to drive for me
yeah because i'm outside
because i'm outside yeah i'm outside
it's easy
uh oh before we got too far i wanted to
do a couple of shout outs
i wanted to give a thank you we got a
new patron we haven't had a new patreon
in a long time yeah we don't get new
patrons
no it's the same pages
anymore well yeah you know it's like
most of the people that are here are
their patrons but yeah we got a new
patron allison
so hey welcome to the show thank you
very much i don't know if you're here
tonight but uh she had sent me an email
earlier
uh about it
and i also wanted to give a thank you to
dermot one of our uk fans
who sent me a 20 pound amazon gift card
to buy time after time because remember
we were talking about that on wednesday
night
about that movie and i was like man i
should probably buy that and uh yeah he
sent me like yeah we gotta buy and do
that so and i got i
although we just watched zardoz i feel
like did we just watch stardust i could
watch that [ __ ] two or three times like
a couple months ago see jenny's weird
about that [ __ ] she'll see weird about
it you have to have to see it again i
see something i like it i want to see it
again
like right after you know who else does
that toddlers
i want to see it again
i want to watch i want to watch beauty
and the beast again yeah i watch it
again
because yeah i remember when my uh when
my siblings were little kids they would
want to watch the same movie like every
day i'll do it too every day yeah
i don't mind watching movies again
yeah but there has to be like a good
like at least a year no
watch it like a day after because i
because i kind of feel like i want some
like perspective on it yeah
i mean i used to watch uh not movies but
i used to watch stuff like uh you know
music videos and stuff like that that i
liked like i would watch those up like a
few times a week and stuff but movies i
just don't have that time that kind of
like time commitment
i don't have the patience for that kind
of stuff
so i will watch that [ __ ] the next day
yeah i know you will yeah
uh oracle says i think it depends on the
movie
yeah i mean there are some movies that i
don't really mind like watching them
over and over
but it's kind of rare
usually i like to have
at least a cushion of time like from the
first time that i watched it till like
the next time look at her what's she
doing just look
why are you mad she's what's up
okay i look back at her and she's laying
like that and she goes
she made a face like that she has little
eyebrows and she goes like
i don't know what she's mad about though
oracle says i spy a pookie i know that
cat butt anywhere
her butt is very distinctive because it
has that little stumpy tail i was
laughing at her earlier because she
jumped up on the sink over there was
drinking out of it and like her butt was
like sticking out like that while she
was like drinking out of the sink she's
[ __ ] crazy she really is
but like i said i was watching some [ __ ]
earlier about like some really jerky
cats and i was just like
well
she's never done anything like that
i don't think she's ever broken anything
not that i can think of she tears up
stuff sometimes like she'll chew things
but
i don't think i've ever had anything
like break because of her you're telling
me to be careful
yeah
well you should
i'm always careful
yeah but
when you've had like a whole bunch of
tequila
it's only like four or five though it's
only four or five tequilas yeah but by
the time i get here it's like seven or
eight so it's a big difference that okay
it's a big difference but i'm just
saying that it's just kind of like if it
was me i just been like wee i don't care
you know what i mean and it's like
that's not really a good situation
[Laughter]
i'm not listening to them no why aren't
you
because you can't tell tom what to do
tom knows better than everybody come
here folk
come here pook you want to get on camera
you want to get on camera everybody
wants to see you pookie come on
she's like i don't i don't know about
this i don't know about this
she's like what what
i look good
why did you why did you pick me up what
are you doing i'm picking you up because
i can pick you up
she's like okay i'll accept it
yeah people are watching look at her
people are watching she's like i don't
know what to do i don't know what to do
about it i'm gonna jump back down she's
like yeah she's getting ready to jump
down right
now yeah oh we got we got a super chat
oh we did oh okay yeah thank you very
much hold on i'm like five seconds
behind yeah thank you very much ian
england have another tequila on me
oh he will yeah i'm sure
but uh but yeah holy crap i can't
believe you had that much i knew you
were gone that a long time but
i do worry about you though because you
were in a wreck before and you were
[ __ ] sober then
so
it happens whether you're sober or not
so it doesn't matter
i don't know i just i don't like it but
you're probably better off if you've
been [ __ ] drinking slightly when you
have a wreck because you're like more
limber you hit the ground more like a
sack of [ __ ] well
well some people said that but then you
don't want to like hurt other people
though that's there's nothing you can do
about it well there is no
[Laughter]
yeah there is like
it's always right tequila is just like a
force of nature it's always random you
know it goes into your mouth
you're reading too much into it towards
random that's what you always say yeah
that's what he always says
every time i [ __ ] wrecked other
people had nothing to do with it it was
[ __ ] cats
oh [ __ ] it's just
you had to be there at the time to
understand it
other people didn't have anything to do
with it
and and uh
other people are not at risk
i don't know if i believe that entirely
if you're not driving a car the
motorcycle only weight lace weighs less
than 400 pounds you can't really do any
damage to anything yeah but what the
[ __ ] am i supposed to do if you get your
dumb ass killed
if i got killed it wouldn't have
anything to do with me
it's always it's always an outside force
that you're not that's not what i asked
you it's totally random that's not what
i asked you
i said what am i supposed to do if you
get your dumb ass killed you would
survive the same way i would survive if
we were both living
[Laughter]
yeah you don't care is what you're
saying no it's just that wouldn't make a
difference wouldn't make it there that's
what that's what i just said
it wouldn't make a difference
you don't care it wouldn't make it there
you go we're all gonna die anyway
yeah okay we all die anyway well yeah
everybody knows that yeah everybody
knows that so nothing means anything and
it's like so okay doesn't mean see
anything
it doesn't
it's like what is the meaning of all
this well what is what is the meaning of
life you're gonna say well yeah i don't
know what to mean what is the meaning of
life of a cat oh uh
the meaning of the life of candace is
what is the meaning of a life of a
[ __ ] worm
what is the meaning of life of an amoeba
of an amoeba
we don't know
you know don't over analyze then your
[ __ ] will be too stressed out
you know just let it ride just don't
care about anything that's tom's advice
don't worry don't worry about anything
don't care about anything that's
something well it's not about care it's
about worrying don't worry about
anything yeah but worry like stems from
care if you didn't care about anything
you look like a sociopath and you
consequently say let's say you're
worried about something and i die and it
negatively affects you
you would be negatively affected for a
while
and then you'd recuperate and then
something bad would happen to you and
then you die and then you die
and you'd be forgotten but that's the
same thing with everybody it doesn't
matter we all die and we're all
forgotten
eventually
so in the end it doesn't matter we're
all going to the same place
just don't think about it that much
you just take it as it
you can comes the hvac says don't die
tom yeah um i might die well i will i
will die eventually i might die now i
might die later it doesn't really matter
because it all it because it always ends
up you're dying anyway yeah but the
thing about that attitude is it's like
in a little
in a way it's like kind of nihilistic
because like i said it gives you license
to not give a [ __ ] about anything or
anybody
um gives you license to rise up above it
but that's the same thing yeah that's
the same thing yeah zatuishi said the
same thing
he says you're gonna die anyway you
might as well die
[ __ ] fighting fighting for the things
you believe in
you know it's better to go ahead and
[ __ ] die fighting for what you're
believing in
then just [ __ ] living in a state of
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up-ness
you know where other people are [ __ ]
you over
life is not as important as you think it
is
you're not immortal you're not immortal
well nobody is duh everybody knows that
i'm just saying i would submit that it's
like it does matter because it matters
to people it's like it doesn't matter in
the grand scheme of things but nobody is
talking about that we're already old
death to us is us is only a few years
anyway granthar says tonight's topic
nihilism nihilism pretty much yeah
once you get once you get into your 50s
death you know death the difference in
life and death is only a decade or so
anyway which that's not much that's my
not much to worry about
but i'm not negative i don't think about
it it's just it's just i just let it
[ __ ] happen sheila says it would matter
to jenny yeah well he doesn't care if it
matters to me or not
it would only matter to her for a
certain point for a certain certain
amount of time he doesn't care for a
certain amount of time then she would
die
wow you're a ray of sunshine tonight
aren't you maybe you shouldn't go to the
bar and like have people buy you drinks
so you're like bumming me out now it's
not bummer it's not it's not being
bumped out yeah it is no that's where
strength comes from
is it yeah okay
strength that's his story strength comes
from the fact that it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter so again because it's
all eventual it's all eventually going
to happen anyway isn't that right poogie
we're all going to die but it's okay
we're all going to die together and then
we'll be on the other side we're going
to be in we're going to be in spirit
land
flying around flying around with the
stars and [ __ ] no we're not yeah
we know i believe so
pookie thinks you're polishing when
we're flying around in stars and [ __ ]
and then we'll [ __ ] reincarnate and
come back with something else
as a worm and then a wasp will rape you
and then all the [ __ ] yeah
it's all like video that's what would
happen to me probably it's all like a
video game
you know what i mean tammy says uh we're
not old my grandmother lived to be 102.
yeah my my grandmother actually lived
into her my great grandmother actually
lived into her 90s and actually might
still be alive she had she actually
committed suicide but um the older you
she had it the older you get the faster
the time flies by a year is the smaller
[ __ ] fraction of your life
so i can sit back and sleep for like six
or seven months or wake up go damn and
another in another six months it'd be
time for another year
this doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter you're worried too much
you [ __ ] are worried it'll be all
right
everything is fun
everything is easy
for you no it's all these
[Laughter]
for you
i make it easy
it's in your mind you make it easy
no
that's not that's not people people try
to over complicate things that's not the
way it works yeah worried too much
anything could happen we could be living
like this and the next you know
lightning bolt comes back and [ __ ]
boom well yeah i know i'm very aware of
it and i'm [ __ ] just reduced to dust
or it could be you [ __ ] lightning
bolt comes that hits you and you're
reduced to dust you we don't know what
can happen
you can't you can't plan
for it well no i know that every day
i know that i'm just saying that i don't
worry about [ __ ] like that i mean kind
of but it's like i know i can't control
that so it's like i'm not worried about
that i do worry about things i can
control though that make my life better
in the here and now yeah because
if i'm gonna be alive for x amount of
years however long it is or like i said
i could get hit by a bus tomorrow i
don't think i'd get hit by a bus because
where the [ __ ] would i get hit by a bus
but you know unless it comes through the
house but you know what i mean um so i
kind of feel like well
day to day you should probably like at
least worry about stuff that is going to
make your life better on a day-to-day
basis so you do have to like worry and
care about stuff like that because
otherwise you're just like laying around
sleeping
not giving a [ __ ] about anything and
then you're dead you know what i mean
that's how it is but like i said it's
that's dumb though because it's like you
you're not really enjoying anything yeah
i know you're not really enjoying what
is that meaning what is the meaning of
life what is the meaning of life but i
think i mean what is the meaning of life
of a cat what is the meaning of life of
a [ __ ] amoeba most people i know that
that that died they lived normal lives
and [ __ ] just died and it didn't mean
anything look a little look at look at
all the friends that we know that died
was there a meaning there no
well what did i just say i said there's
not a greater meaning because i'm an
atheist it's like i know there's not a
meaning like in the grand scheme of the
universe or whatever yeah i know that
doesn't matter but like i said you're
alive you're conscious
so i kind of feel like your whole thing
and when we're talking about cats and
stuff like that too my whole thing is to
like make her life
as pleasant as possible
because that's all there is yeah
so you should try to like enjoy things i
do
you know what i mean look you seem like
you don't though no i enjoy all kinds
[ __ ] i'm having fun look at kaylee
kaylee died
what would have happened to kaylee if
she had lived longer
not much more than well i don't know who
knows
she'd have been about like that
she'd have been about like that then
she'd have gotten old and she wouldn't
have been cute
and then people would have not [ __ ]
been too interested in her she had
watched television looked at on been
surf the web
and eventually would have gotten
forgotten
and she'd have been living off [ __ ]
paychecks that got sent to her
i don't know [ __ ] for in unemployment
and then she would have died
so there wouldn't have been a big
difference really but would she have
enjoyed that time though yeah i mean if
you could come to her
like because she died when she was 34
yeah it's like if you could have come to
her and said hey
you know do you would you like train
whatever you want like do you want to
live longer even if you're just like
sitting around watching tv you [ __ ] yeah
she would have said yeah of course
because you have to learn to appreciate
the little things because like i said
that's kind of all there is right you
know what i mean you just have to kind
of like find some [ __ ] but you look
at the difference between 30 years and
300 years there isn't really that much
of a difference when you look at things
when from the point of view of the
universe when you're talking about
billions of years and trillions of years
and eight billion years and because we
don't live really we don't really live
long to begin with
so there's nothing we can really do
about it i don't worry about it tom's
too cool for this [ __ ] i'm too cool for
that [ __ ] i don't worry about it
we don't live long anyway well i mean
the rest of us care about stuff and the
rest of us are talking about we'll just
let tom not care about anything you're
gonna die because he's too cool we're
gonna well duh everybody knows that
everybody already knows that you're like
acting like nobody knows that it's gonna
be all right
like you're imparting some grand wisdom
it's like yeah duh everybody knows that
yeah
it's gonna be all right ian england says
maybe the amoeba is doing amoeba coke
off amoeba strippers butts yeah
yeah yeah
you don't know well like i said that's
why i like to give animals the benefit
of the doubt man i'm depressing
everybody don't worry yeah you are
don't worry about it people you are i'm
not yeah
i know i'm not depressed about it
well but yeah but you're depressing
everybody else though yeah
[Laughter]
we're philosophical tonight instead of
talking about food well that's because
we haven't had any food today so we
haven't had any like food to talk about
you made some really nice wet burritos
last night though yeah those are very i
went down and eat some [ __ ] uh
chickpeas i ate chickpeas oh i didn't
eat anything yeah they had some down
there i just warmed them beat them
oh why didn't you tell me you were
warming them up i make you sound you
want some no it's too late now all right
you should have said something yeah it
wasn't very much just i say the peanut
butter sandwich i didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on that's all i had
peanut butter sandwich some chickpeas
see what everybody's doing what do they
say granthar says tonight's topics
tequila death justin's he-man
kimmy and brazilian women
you talk about kimmy already well yeah
yeah well not already it's almost an
hour in yeah what do you have to say
about kimmy anything
anything else you'd you'd like to see
kimmy was uh was my babysitter when i
was a little kid in case you guys are
yeah
princess leia she looks just like
princess leia look at she's look like uh
i showed her pictures of her here
on the show she did she looked like uh
princess leia
yeah
she took me to see all kinds of stuff
when i was kid
i remember you saying to like her and
her little friends because they were
like a lot older than you and they would
like kind of carry you around like a
teddy bear yeah a tiny bear they were
teenagers
they were [ __ ] smoking pot listening
to [ __ ] uh led zeppelin
they pass you around sister golden hair
or whatever yeah like yeah no no let's
happen they listen to zombies
they'll be listening to [ __ ] houses
of holy and [ __ ]
i remember that [ __ ] album cover
and then uh go down to the drive and
[ __ ] take me and see uh
sinbad sinbad and the [ __ ]
all right the tiger sandbag and the
[ __ ] i think i saw that as driving
also yeah now that i'm thinking about it
did we do it i know we did a couple of
sinbad because we kind of went through a
thing like a few months back well
actually this was like
probably some time before
it was some time before we moved here
because we were like still at the old
house we were watching like a bunch of
sinbad movies
we watched eye of the tiger again i
don't like that one as much
as some of the other voyages yeah some
yeah seventh voyage just said that is
better
um but i think sinbad in the eye of the
tiger i saw it a lot like i saw the
drive-in and then i saw it on cable i
think when i was like a kid so yeah
i remembered liking that one a lot from
childhood i guess that was about seven
or so maybe about seven years old
they'd take me to the uh
take me to the matinee
kimmy and her friends
and we'd see [ __ ] horror movies and
[ __ ]
they
took me to see the evil
i think they took me to see [ __ ] uh
amityville [ __ ]
i know i at least saw the the uh the
woody color
i know that i at least saw the trailer
to amityville with her
man i remember a good time when i saw
amityville horror i was probably only
seven or eight yeah that would be scared
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me holy crap
like when you watch it now it's not
really all that scary yeah but when i
saw it when i was little i was like holy
nope i was like seven eight ten i was
doing during that time
i guess um
i guess i stopped having a babysitter i
was probably around ten but she just
lived next door to me
okay i didn't know she lived next door
no should live live next door okay two
hou two houses over
uh okay so you know um she was like a
full-time babysitter
whenever my mom was going out
and going anywhere [ __ ] kimmy would
watch me so i kind of grew up around
kimmy she was kind of like my older
sister i guess in a way
during that time i never had babysitters
because my parents
um
well for a while when i was a little bit
older but like my parents ran a daycare
like at it's outside like they had a
daycare and then like for a while my mom
had one in the house that was when i was
a little bit older that's when my sister
was really little so that was like late
70s because yeah my sister was born in
79 so it was like 79.80 but um prior to
that whenever my parents had to work
which was pretty much always we went and
stayed with my grandma my dad's you know
my dad's mom yeah so we like would stay
over there all summer and we would
usually go there like after school and
stuff like that because my parents were
both working obviously yeah so we always
had her so i grew up like
pretty much 50 50 like with my parents
and my grandparents right
i don't remember how old kimmy was she
was probably about 16 or 17. she was old
enough to drive
eventually
and because no she was driving me
and i guess i was probably around 10 at
that time
yeah i was laughing tyler the guy said
for some reason i imagined kid tom just
being a small version of what he looks
like now yeah
no i had hair somebody needs to like fun
i don't know why i just thought of this
did somebody like have some toys oh i
remember what they were i had hair you
remember those uh the toys that were
like those kind of stuff like the plush
things of like the wrestlers like the
wwf or wwe wrestlers that they had like
in the 90s
i kind of like whenever i think of you
as a kid and like the babies that are
like taking you around i picture that
like one of those like what them walking
around with one of those wwe like plush
dolls like under their arms
he actually i've seen pictures of him as
a kid
uh he actually kind of looked like
damien yeah they would say that he
looked like damien yeah kimmy would say
[ __ ] look he's he's damien he's the
kid for [ __ ] omen i didn't know what
they were talking about but i had the
same curly hair and [ __ ] yeah
yeah and you probably had the same
personality
[Laughter]
she'd take me to all her friends houses
they'd be over there [ __ ] throwing
parties and [ __ ] smoking weed and
[ __ ]
because they were they were california
teenagers
you know so i was i grew up around
[ __ ] you know what i mean
bad influences i guess i don't know but
it was just the way it was back then
the way it was
yeah you probably got all kind of
contact high back then yeah probably
probably maybe that's what you're
probably it was fun you know they were
[ __ ] you know 16 15 16 17 year old
girls mostly with guys who are a little
bit older and then just me i was
probably they're like look we have seven
eight nine ten eleven you know running
let's tuck him under his arm and take
him to see like [ __ ]
yeah you see horror movies and [ __ ]
that's what you are right there yeah
uh
a lot of hippie actors and i the tiger
yeah there were yeah um gilded h phoenix
says the original amityville horror was
amazingly scary i remember watching that
on select division over and over again
yeah i saw it a bunch of times when i
was a kid it's scared well i kind of
feel like
horror movie like that scared me the
shining scared me when i saw that in
1980 or 1981
but
it scared me but i still wanted to like
watch it again you know what i mean so i
kind of feel like that's what
differentiates a horror person from a
non-horror person
because i didn't realize this at the
time because i
i don't know ever since i was a kid i
was just like i like scary [ __ ] and i
just wanted all the scary things but i
didn't realize that there are some
people that absolutely will not watch
horror movies i didn't realize there's a
whole subset
of people
i don't know maybe some maybe some of
the people in the chat or people i doubt
it but
but they will not watch horror movies
because they're too scary but they want
to know what happens in the horror
movies so they will just read the
wikipedia synopsis of the plot
and then be like ooh scary you know what
i mean but they won't actually watch it
which
okay you do you but that is very very
weird that's very weird to me
now i have seen some movies that
i kind of dreaded watching
like if it's real
like if it has a reputation for being
really like i don't know like if there's
a lot of really unpleasant [ __ ] in it
like there's a lot of hey somebody
drinks a bowl of vomit or something like
that
then i'll kind of be like uh do i really
want to watch this and [ __ ] like that
but usually i'm all about it
i'm all about it granthar says uh tom is
exactly the same as he was in high
school just a bit more worldwide now
yeah
yeah i get that yeah
yeah and she uh and and um
oh [ __ ] wasn't sam i don't know
i'm kind of loaded
yeah obviously
i proved it before i was talking about
kimmy
and i said she looked like
she looked like carrie fisher and i
[ __ ] pulled a photograph out and
showed the [ __ ] showed everybody the
audience she did she looked just like
carrie fisher
even jenny was like yeah she does she
looks like carrie fisher
that's exactly how she look like
and she was during those days she was
anywhere between 13 to probably about 16
or 17.
that's
because you know she lived next door to
me for [ __ ] forever so i moved away
she probably even knew me when i was
[ __ ] three or four
because she grew up next door to me
so she would have been
probably about 10
or so when
when i was born maybe around that time i
don't know i was probably about two or
three she's probably about 10.
my mom knew her mom
tammy says my stepfather got our 17 year
old babysitter pregnant and then ended
up marrying her after my mom divorced
him damn that's uh pretty [ __ ] up damn
that's pretty [ __ ] up she might have
been hot
yeah but i'm just saying now we will
we'll get into this sunday because the
movie that we're gonna talk about on
sunday malone yeah reynolds yeah yeah
we're gonna talk about it has some uh
kind of like
i don't know jamie was getting dad and
teen well i wasn't upset about it i was
just kind of like
are we going there are these like dude
she's like [ __ ] 17 years old come on
i think she was supposed to be older
than that
she wasn't though because like the [ __ ]
in her room was like kid stuff like
teenage like a teenage girl would have
well i think she had been living at home
for a long time right but you would
still like modernize i don't think she
was like a teenager i think she was
maybe 19 or 20.
i don't know she read younger to me
she write younger she read like the way
she was actually looked young and she
the way she was acting was like a
teenage girl she wasn't acting like a
girl in there in there this is late 80s
though i mean [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
went it was going down like that so well
at least they didn't go there because
like i'm watching the movie
is this gonna
like is this gonna go like weirdly like
dad daughter porn it's like i'm just i'm
not about it it's like really creeping
me out a little bit but he was probably
about what 40 something i don't know how
old he was but i don't know i don't know
how old he was supposed to be
but she was probably about 20 i think
the actress might have been 20 but like
i said the character read younger to me
right she read like 17. the way i took
it was is that she was like a woman in
her very early 20s
who had not left home
and had a lot of
girlish stuff in her room still that's
how i had some unfulfilled desires well
she had never left home
well yeah that's what i mean so so some
handsome older stranger blows into town
remember her dad wasn't upset about it
with a crazy hairpiece yeah and she
wants
some of that her dad
her dad wasn't upset about it i think he
was maybe 20 years old the dad was
played by herschel by the walking dead
yeah scott walker yeah he was in in cold
blood too
i know it's very reductive did you say
he was herself on the walking dead but i
kind of feel like that's how people
would remember him right uh because he
passed away didn't he like a couple
years ago but yeah he was in a [ __ ] ton
of stuff like uh in the 60s and 70s um
crafter says uh tonight's episode is
going to be classic i can tell yeah uh
oh i'm sure probably well i might need
another uh i might need another drink
you know here uh gilded age phoenix says
the exorcist pea soup scene i didn't
like it yeah i'm
honestly it's
it doesn't bother me vomit doesn't
bother me as much as it used to
uh in real life or in movies i still
don't love it
um used to be when i was growing i know
there's a word for it but when i was
growing up i couldn't even like hear
like if one of my uh siblings got sick
like you know or something and was
throwing up in the bathroom i couldn't
either
block my ears or i would throw up as
well so there was that
and uh so it took me a long time to
really get over that and like when i was
watching a movie and somebody threw up
in it and like for whatever reason like
a lot of movies just seemed like hey
let's have somebody puke in a movie
and i was just kind of like why do we
need to show that i don't know but so
like you they'd show it or like the
noise or something like that and i'd be
like yeah i can't watch that because it
would make me gag
um it doesn't bother me as much anymore
but
it's usually not too bad as long as it's
not too egregious and it's like if the
noise isn't too like
it's i don't know squishy um but
yeah if you if it goes like the full
audition route where it's like you know
you're making somebody drink it or
something like that i'm like yeah no
thank you no thank you i am fast
forwarding through that [ __ ] like i said
anything to do with
vomiting or pooping or peeing to a
lesser extent
yeah like bodily fluids not having it
honestly i can watch gore all day long
um you know you can just [ __ ] do
whatever the [ __ ] you just you know
crack somebody's rib cage open and eat
their heart i don't give a [ __ ] about
that that doesn't gross me out but
anything having to do with like vomit or
poop no thanks no thanks
um yeah so it took me a while to like
get through the pea soup scene
like i used to kind of like watch it
like that because i'm like ah
but then i was just kind of like well i
try to i i would have to like tell
myself it's not really vomit it's not
really vomit it's not really vomit
and nobody drank it so i was okay so i
can watch it now you know
um
yeah we're getting into porn fantasy
stuff now i honestly i kind of want to
talk about that like on because like i
said we watched this movie uh malone
with burt reynolds and we just found it
randomly i think it was on amazon prime
and we watched it and i said oh we'll
talk about that on the sunday matinee
show
and it was a later film it was the 80s
but i can't remember what year it was
and um
and there was like yeah so it was like
kind of uncomfortable they didn't like
go the direction that i thought because
i'm like oh my god is it or she's being
introduced as a love interest because
she's like clearly a teenager and i was
like kind of weirded out because i'm
like burt reynolds was not old old but
he was very clearly old enough to be her
dad and then some
so i was just kind of like yeah but at
least they didn't go there so you know
[Laughter]
oh my god
oracle says i work in healthcare i know
a ton of words to describe disgusting
stuff
oh my god yeah my sister used to do
medical coding
for a gi clinic
so she
got all the fun uh stuff that she used
to code like you know people getting
stuff
lodged in their colons and whatnot so
she always had like really good stories
about that
but i always kind of wanted to hear them
but then i was just like oh
why did i want to like listen to that
but you know dermot says the dog with
the man's head on it from invasion of
the body snatchers freaked me out for
years afterwards that's still i would
submit that that is still a great image
because it's just so
unsettling it was weird i mean because
it was just so unexpected it just kind
of like comes up out of nowhere and it
doesn't like really factor into the plot
all that much it's just like this random
yeah like [ __ ] weird image
and i kind of feel like that's why it's
so effective i really like that movie
it's just there's something like the
vibe of that one is just like so [ __ ]
strange
and i don't think that can be replicated
that was just like a 70s thing a lot of
70s movies had that weird [ __ ]
vibe to it
that i don't that you can't really like
replicate nowadays
ian england says was listening to
terence pop the other day someone wrote
in a story about someone's stomach
backing up and throwing up [ __ ] honestly
um terence pop i don't want to talk
about that too much because i'll start
to gag but
uh we used to watch
i think it was monsters inside me
yeah and one of the guys on there and i
still remember this because it was so
gross he had a similar thing happen like
he had some kind of like
backup
and yeah he started like throwing up
[ __ ] because it couldn't come out it
usually has some do those damn
[ __ ] little uh metal [ __ ] barbs
from the dam
well yeah we brought that up
that's there was like more one of those
cleaner yeah
yeah i didn't realize and like i said i
guess that's why the ones they sell now
are like plastic although i don't see
how that would be any better like one of
the plastic ones because it's like
softer than metal i guess
but
and i it's weird because i never even
thought about it and then i was just
like oh my god holy [ __ ] yeah you clean
the [ __ ] barbecue with this metal
brush the one of the things
comes off like one of the bristles gets
in your burger
and you just eat it and then it's like
perforating all your [ __ ] inside like
holy crap
humans are so
vulnerable
[Laughter]
we're so soft and it's just like it just
takes this little mini thing like that
like poke holes all up in your [ __ ] yeah
that's [ __ ] scary this is like i'm
fascinated by that show but
like watching that kind of like stress
me out too because like some of the
people there were like again like not
doing it they just ate a burger or they
were like walking in a park or they were
just doing like regular [ __ ] and then
all of a sudden they're like you know
[ __ ] out their intestines and stuff
like that because of some [ __ ] weird
parasite or whatnot
holy crap
but um
yeah
tyler the guy says the 70 movies looked
more warm and they were like
uh they were like set and lived in
worlds modern stuff looks too sterile
yeah
well i think there's a lot of 70s 70s
movies that you're watching were kind of
just filmed on location in jail
locations what they had that's what they
had yeah and then later on
a lot of this [ __ ] that's modern they're
trying to film it on somebody's set a
lot of it has to do with spreading money
around inside the industry you know
there's not as much uh
there's not as much [ __ ] realism in
movies today that's why a lot of them
suck
but you know you're only going to be
able to do what you have to do it's an
industry
well and i think too that sometimes i
think some and i get this like sometimes
like particular directors or movie
makers they're like we want like a
fantasy we want to create our whole
entire world
you know that they can control maybe
where i feel like the 70s movies they
wanted well 60s and 70s i kind of feel
like was more
the heyday
of
realism because you were just coming out
of
you know 40s 50s which was a lot more
stagey
and people were kind of used to
you know seeing things on sets and [ __ ]
like that whereas in the 60s and 70s
they started filming a lot more on
location and like in real places so
you know people kind of got the vibe of
like things that were like real and i
kind of feel like people
got a lot more into that uh aesthetic
whereas
when you got like later on people
i kind of feel like they went more in
like a fantasy based direction where
they wanted to like create these whole
entire worlds especially now that they
have cgi and they can literally create a
whole entire world inside a computer so
there's that kind of thing oh so
everybody's talking about the the
barfing scene the pie eating scene and
stand by me i still can't watch that
honestly i might be more grossed out
nowadays
uh i might be less grossed out by
vomiting than i am about watching people
eat a lot like i can't watch um you know
this like competitive eating competition
not not that i would watch those but i'm
just saying that i can't watch those
actually for a while i was watching man
versus food is that even still on i
don't think it is
where that guy would go and eat he'd go
around the country and like eat the
[ __ ] 40 pound burger or whatever the
hell he'd go to like every restaurant
that had these big like eating
challenges and he would go and do them i
had a hard time watching that without
feeling nauseated
because it's like watching people eat
i've always been real grossed out by
watching people eat especially if
they're eating like loudly or
if it's eating something that's like
really fatty or like with a lot of gravy
on it or something it's like i have a
hard time watching people eat i don't
like it but yeah so that's gross to me
also it's worse if i can hear it too
like the sound of it
you know yeah i don't know i don't like
it
uh oracle says this is why food safety
is important yeah you know
grimther says james cameron has four
avatar movies in the hopper that he's
been working on for 10 years he's not
going to do that i don't think i'm gonna
sit through four more fake world avatar
movies unless i'm at a coma state yeah
it's like the first one was fine but
it's like
i think we said this on one of our other
shows where i was like avatar is one of
those movies where it's like everybody
it was like a huge thing like at the
time and everybody saw it but then like
a year or two later everyone kind of
forgot about it like it didn't have a
lot of staying power like it was very
like you know of the moment well there
wasn't a follow-up in time
and uh
then he came out with elite elite battle
angel
he produced that that was a great movie
but then they didn't want to [ __ ]
make a follow-up they didn't want you
know and you'll never see it again
directors have
half-lives
and uh that particular director has
reached his if you ask me
cameron you're not going to see anything
good from him anymore he's he's too
old too rich and too lazy
a good director is a [ __ ] young and a
hungry director
who's trying to make a name for himself
or if they're older they're a weirdo
yeah like david lynch yeah lynch
or his son where they don't like yeah or
no david cronenberg that's who he is
david lynch has a daughter jennifer
lynch right who is also a director well
that [ __ ] was weird but the
cronenbergs were they were both good
both cronenbergs yeah i'm kind of
digging uh the brandon cronenberg movies
i've only seen a couple of them but uh
yeah he's following it down but he's got
his own kind of thing on it too
cronenberg just [ __ ] he had a good
dad who knew about making movies and uh
when he's making his movies that he's
got his own signature on him
they're not
cronenberg copies but you definitely see
the lineage
definitely
yeah he's got his own obsessions but
like i said
you know you're gonna see that because
they're i mean that's his son obviously
so they're gonna be similar in a lot of
ways and if he goes into the similar
kind of line of work yeah they're gonna
have like similar obsessions about
you know bodily invasion and that kind
of stuff
which was one of his big things yeah
but uh
yeah most of these directors have a
half-lives i mean
and that includes
that includes spielberg
i mean
he was good but he was better when he
was younger
yeah generally like artistic and this
isn't always the case but artistically
it's not just movies it's music it's
anything writers all their writers tend
to be a little bit older when they start
out
but
generally something like music or movies
usually they're better when they're
younger yeah
but
i mean not always but like i said i kind
of feel like the particular thing that
we're talking about now like james
cameron steven spielberg you know george
lucas stuff like that
i kind of feel like their their younger
[ __ ] was better because i think they got
all this success
and it's really hard
to still be
creative and out there and [ __ ] like
that when you just have like money
thrown at you like all the time
so
and lucas was never great as a director
he was a great he's an id he's an idea
guy he's a conceptual kind of guy
he was good at certain things but he
needed supervision
i mean star wars was saved and edit by
his wife
um
thx 1138 had a lot of good stuff in it
but he's not somebody you want to have a
final say on things
he's somebody you want to be in the mix
to come up with the idea
but you want somebody else to tell him
no
because
you can't do george that's dumb yeah you
can't trust him on his own
well some people like that like i said
some
you have some people like like i said
david lynch or david croninberg
something like that they have a very
singular vision yeah and they're gonna
do their [ __ ] and it's very distinctive
and it's all it's always worth watching
yeah and then you have people and i'm
not saying it's one thing's better than
the other i'm just saying that sometimes
you have people that are like really
really good at one thing
but not very good at other things and
like i said movie making is a very
collaborative process yeah and it's not
i mean it's really not um
something that is necessarily one
person's vision yeah because you have
all these other people working on it and
like input their input too the best star
wars movies had lucas in them but they
were basically british movies
yeah
they were finished movies sure and they
were british world war ii movies
when you looked at [ __ ]
empire strikes back which is the best of
them all
there isn't a whole lot of george lucas
in that it's a british world war ii
movie
pretty much yeah and then when he
started to have almost full control like
in his prequels they weren't bad they're
better than
the [ __ ] they're making today but
they just didn't i don't know i think i
like the more recent ones more than the
prequels i still hate the prequels i
think the prequels were better
well it's just a matter of a taste the
sith one was good but like the first two
were just awful
i thought they were okay they were at
least star wars and i watched them
several times i gave them a chance
because i saw them in the theater and i
was kind of like i was hyped but then i
was like i kind of feel like i didn't
like that but that can't be right and
then but like later on like i watched
him again i'm like nope nope i hated it
i hated it
the third one was good but the first two
were awful
grant there's hammer says man vs food
guy casey webb is still on holy [ __ ] now
with a bmi of 44 uh yeah i can imagine
yeah you just probably just got fatter
and fatter i was like i kind of liked
that show
but
i don't know i had a hard time watching
it because i can imagine myself in that
situation because i can't eat [ __ ] i
couldn't even eat like a [ __ ]
hundredth of what he eats like in one
sitting or i would barf all over
and
i could just see it in his face that he
just like really wanted to like [ __ ]
throw up and i'm just kind of like i
don't i can't watch it anymore so i
couldn't watch when it comes to the new
star wars force awakens wasn't that bad
but then when last jedi and the other
one came out i was like nah
they're just i just didn't think they
were good at all
and it was it was the writing
although you know the second one last
jedi was probably one of the better
looking ones it looked good but i just
didn't like the story
as soon as i saw some of the [ __ ] that
happened i was like oh no
no this [ __ ] the tone was just all
wrong
just wasn't star wars to me
the first couple um [ __ ] series of
the mandalorians first couple episodes
uh first couples uh
become seasons of it we're pretty good
uh i i've heard that boba fett's pretty
bad
um so i did we haven't watched it yet i
heard it was bad so i didn't bother with
it
um
it definitely didn't did not too good
um
mandalorian if they keep going with it
it would be good probably
but you know i i don't care i don't care
anymore i think i think uh
i think disney's [ __ ]
there's just something wrong with disney
disney can't handle those properties
they're too corporate it's just too
[ __ ] corporate
those
star wars is supposed to be something
kind of like a [ __ ]
samurai movie and a old west movie and
it was
that writing came from another era and
uh
the talent doesn't exist today
not not not in the united states
maybe another country but
but then you take it to another country
and they wouldn't understand it because
it's got to be a western
grantham says martin score says he is
old but still has game yeah he does
because i've seen some of his more
recent movies and they are very good
tyler the guy says and this is kind of
interesting he says sam worthington is
the leading man in avatar
it's the highest grossing film of all
time and barely anyone knows who
worthington is that's kind of surreal
yeah and it's like i think did i bring
that up because we just reviewed
rogue that australian crocodile killer
crocodile movie sam worthington was in
that before
avatar
and
i was kind of like oh my god it's sam
worthington and
then it was just kind of like oh this is
before avatar so he got killed like
halfway through and it's just like funny
i haven't seen him i'm sure he's been a
lot of stuff since then because i know
that name but you know what i mean i
haven't seen him in a lot of stuff and
then grant this also said uh clint
eastwood is still going strong at 95.
and honestly we've seen
that that what was the last one that we
saw in the theater the mule the mule
that was actually that was excellent
yeah i forgot i liked that a lot about
an old guy working for the damn mexican
drug cartels although like i said clint
eastwood he's 95 man yeah he looks it
too yeah man he looks like a [ __ ]
mummy looks like a [ __ ] corpse
walking around but you know
you live to 95 it's like he probably
like i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i got a
right to look like this yeah he was old
when i was young
he was one of those guys that always i
kind of feel like that generation like
always looked like old guys because
sometimes
i would see like i would see some movie
in the 80s that had like some old actor
in it and then like i'd see a movie that
came out in the 50s that had that action
when they were young and i'm like they
still look kind of old though yeah i was
like did they always look like they were
40
like even when they were like 20 i kind
of feel like they did
hey graham i'll tell you what i remember
uh [ __ ] me and
me and
steve
went to the drive-in
to watch pale rider
and steve had heidi crapel with him and
i had terry remember little terry a
little little little dark-haired terry
she was [ __ ] cute [ __ ] little goth
girls even [ __ ] heidi
and [ __ ] those girls were [ __ ]
lusting over [ __ ] old uh
um
[ __ ]
what's his name i don't know dude from
[ __ ] man i'm [ __ ] high
oh
clayton eastwood
really yeah clintus was probably [ __ ]
in his late 40s early 50s
and and steve was like heidi heidi would
you do him you know that kind of [ __ ]
is he cute and [ __ ] hot he's like
yeah he's pretty hot and [ __ ] um
girls back in the day [ __ ] who they
were teenagers
and [ __ ] uh [ __ ] terry was like
yeah he's pretty hot
he was he was an all-right looking dude
when he was younger it's like not my
type but you know he's like 47 45 almost
50. well yeah
darren pale ryder
and um
[ __ ] the girls we were dating back
when we were t when we were high school
and teenagers you know [ __ ] heidi and
heidi and terry were probably about
16 or 17 at that time maybe 17.
and uh no they [ __ ] thought he was
great
they were just like wishing that you
guys were all like silent and mysterious
yeah exactly like clint eastwood exactly
exactly
exactly when girls were into that [ __ ]
yeah they're all like silent mysterious
[Laughter]
i mean steve looking at each other like
god damn
[ __ ] you know i mean jealous old
[ __ ]
yeah oh [ __ ] clitty clint eastwood
yeah he wasn't really the first person
that i thought like i said it's not
really my type i like clint eastwood
movies um but i don't know he was a
good-looking dude when he was younger
yeah
like i said now he looks like a mommy
but like i said he's 95 so he's earned
the right to look like that i'm just
saying he was old when we were young
that's what i'm saying like i've seen
some [ __ ] when he was like yeah like all
the [ __ ] sergio leone movies and
stuff like he's fairly young in that 30s
that's what i mean he's younger than me
yeah now
so it's just kind of like yeah he was
young in that yeah i don't know there
was a way and we've talked about this
before there was like a weird thing
i kind of feel like the boomer
generation specifically
even when they were like
30
they seemed like they were
old
they looked old they acted old
not all of them but it was just it was a
really really weird it was really weird
all right grandma because i remember one
time being at steve's and carrie was
there and heidi stopped by unannounced
and things got a little awkward oh yeah
[ __ ] i know he's talking about
steve was going out with carrie and he
was trying to dump carrie
for [ __ ] heidi
yeah i remember when that [ __ ] was going
down
but a lot of things a lot of things that
people didn't know and you know the
shit's blown over now [ __ ] it's now
modern day we can say it
[ __ ] kerry was pregnant
yeah she was pregnant
steve got her pregnant went all that
[ __ ] going down that's [ __ ] some wild
[ __ ]
are you like talking about actually
people making people pregnant yeah the
old days maybe they don't want that
don't
you know i think everybody knows
all his friends knew everybody knows
because suck and then
carrie wanted to kill her kill a [ __ ]
and it was like well you know
it wasn't my girlfriend that was on
steve you know what i mean
but steve got her pregnant
i remember when it should happen
and [ __ ] carrie was older than steve
by a couple of years i think if i
remember correctly
graham might remember
i think did he not believe in condoms or
what
i think she tried to get pregnant
think so did he not believe in condoms i
don't know i don't know i wouldn't
i wasn't there i wasn't in the middle of
the [ __ ] jenny [ __ ] don't well
like i said you can't i'm not blaming
yourself
i'm just saying it's like a lot of guys
are like oh the girl didn't take her
birth control and fooled me into it i'm
like did you wear a condom no well then
yeah
that was some weird it's kind of on you
though that's back in the 80s man you
got to have like both things
just to make sure yeah if you really
don't want kids yeah just saying
gilded age phoenix says come on tom who
could have this man i didn't know that
oh yeah yeah that's why that [ __ ] blew
up the way it was that's why that's why
this [ __ ] blew up the way that it did
somebody mentioned uh guilty i didn't
have nothing to do with it
i didn't have anything to do with it no
one thought you did tom no i was just
ancient history and there's nothing that
i even know about yeah and then and then
[ __ ]
carrie tried to get even with him by
[ __ ] me and i didn't take the bait i
didn't take the bait i was like nah
because i i didn't i figured she'd
probably flip it around say it was my
baby
she didn't have the baby anyway though
she had but you know how it is
papa don't preach yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
all right anyway
uh so gillette h phoenix brings up
howard the duck now
i will not have any bad words said about
howard the duck because as [ __ ] up as
that movie it is it's george lucas
that's why they were talking about it
yeah
i kind of have a soft spot for howard
the duck yeah i saw it a bunch of times
when i was growing up and
i kind of love it i kind of like love
how weird it is i specifically like
jeffrey jones who i know is a pedophile
okay so i'm not like we didn't know that
back then
uh the whole thing after he'd been taken
over by an alien and they were in the
diner and then like the waitress takes
his eggs away and he's like she took my
eggs it's like i don't know why like
that was so funny to me but we should do
howard the duck actually
yeah i kind of love that age says it
sounded like a jerry springer episode it
was man
yeah kinda everyone's life is a journey
yeah it's like jerry springer starbucks
78 says george miller is an anomaly
fury road still hasn't been topped i
will agree with that
uh george miller
who is
a very old
and when he came out with fury road
i was just kind of like well
we showed up to tell everybody how to
make a movie
yeah he's like look step aside yeah let
a [ __ ] show you how to make a
movie okay you can make a movie
and uh where what
that's what he did yeah he made the
movie then he's just like he's like
that's it
yeah mike driving and he's not hollywood
he's australian he's an australian
independent filmmaker
and he's like uh yeah everyone was like
look like this is not how you make a
movie
but all of his [ __ ] was good
he needs to live forever
you knew he said that the property is in
good hands if anything happens to him i
know like i'm glad that he like you know
made [ __ ] uh arrangements for that
yeah because
it was time for a new he's a [ __ ]
he's a treasure man yeah
he's a treasure
and it's like oh we'll be sad when he
goes yeah
uh hey jenny have you seen hale caesar
that's a fun look at the golden age of
hollywood i have not
but i will i have heard of it but i
haven't like watch it yeah yeah who can
dislike a duck lusting actually a
thompson
i mean i don't know like i saw in the
80s and it's like i didn't really think
about the implications of it i guess
as this is an
inter-galactic duck
who has the hots for like a human woman
and they have sex in the movie yeah
um
i was just kind of like okay suppose so
like i didn't think it was all that
weird i don't know what that says about
me but i didn't think it was that weird
like in the 80s i was just kind of like
oh okay
uh you know
uh let me say disney wrecks everything
it touches that's panthers
um
isabella says and i guess he's talking
about uh cladyswood
he looks really young in one episode of
mr ed um i saw him in
oh man a 50 sci-fi movie what the [ __ ]
was that
it was the one with [ __ ] john agar
and clint eastwood was like his lab
assistant and there was like a chimp
involved
it's not what you're thinking but yeah
but clint eastwood was like in one scene
he looked kind of young in that but he
still looked kind of old like i i don't
know man it's like the boomer generation
you see them in like movies and i'm just
kind of like i'm always like shocked
when i look up how young they were yeah
they're like oh they were only 28 when
they made this movie and i'm like hold
really i was like i thought they were
like [ __ ] 38
and it's not because they look old it's
just that
i don't know what it is i don't know if
it's just like the cl the cut of the
clothes or the haircuts or i don't know
i don't know what it is it's just it's
very hard to like put a finger on
um
jenny would like eastwood and rawhide
uh sam elliott is another hot older guy
yeah there you go didn't we just see a
movie the other day that had sam elliott
in it as a very young person
well he was in frogs i don't remember
remember that one no frogs
no we just saw it like a few weeks ago
oh okay
it's sam elliot oh yeah yeah and i
almost didn't recognize him because he
didn't have a mustache yeah i remember
now and then i was like then i heard the
voice and i was like wait that's damn
elliot and i was like oh my and then i
looked it up i'm like oh my god it
totally is i remember that
yeah
because i kind of feel like his mustache
was so iconic that like people don't
remember him without the mustache
uh let's see what else uh sounds like a
jerry springer episode yeah
carrie works as a waitress in the area
i've seen her over the years a few times
time has not been kind yeah oh i think
she heidi still looks good though
yeah
i was always cute i wonder where having
a terry
i forgot terry's last name she's a
little brunette
but carrie i think was the drinker
uh you know [ __ ]
but no i i don't know what heidi does
now but how do you how he was always she
was a cutie
you just call her wookie
tall skinny chick little because she was
super hairy yeah she had a long hair
down to her ass we could call her wookie
i used to have that when i was younger
and it was and it was kind of like a
mousy blonde
hair
blue eyes and she had little spectacles
she wore little round spectacles
she was cute that was
that was um that was steve's girlfriend
i was always trying to steal her though
man me and steve were oh we were good
friends we were like brothers so we were
always trying to steal each other's
girlfriends
that was just part of our thing when we
were teenagers
we would laugh about it though
i don't know that's just like funny to
me yeah well it's funny to me because
it's like i don't
hardly remember anything about high
school yeah
trying to see each other's girlfriends
high school was fun but it's like that
was a long time ago and it's like i
don't really remember most of the people
like
any of the people that i liked from high
school which was not very many um i'm
still kind of like friends with them on
facebook and like you know there was
like a handful of people other than that
i don't give a [ __ ] about anybody that
was in high school
that was a long time ago
you know steve used to [ __ ] around
[ __ ] threatened to [ __ ] each other's
moms that was another thing too yeah i
remember you steve was like i'm gonna
[ __ ] your mom this is done you're like
no i [ __ ] your mom already
and we we'd have to lie i had to make up
stories that i [ __ ] his mom and [ __ ]
to counteract it she was funny man
then i started [ __ ] threatened to
[ __ ] his little sister and then he got
mad yeah that's nice don't [ __ ] with a
dude yeah like she was she was she was
old enough but i was just saying yeah
i'm a [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ] little sister i
did this my little sister says yeah but
you [ __ ] my mom so i'm [ __ ] sick
but he was lying we were both lying
it was just it was just the times you
know it was just the time krampus
remembers it
kellen higgins just threads i still
think fury road is better than beyond
thunderdome uh yeah yeah miles better
yeah thunderdome is kind of mediocre in
some ways yeah i'm not a huge fan of
beyond thunderdome uh it's okay
but it's my it's my least favorite of
the entire series thunderdome had the
wrong tone it felt very american and it
was very sing-songy and repetitive well
it was kind of like a bigger budget like
more corporate big studio
type movie it wasn't like a scrappy like
australian
and it had an okay it had a the look was
kind of correct but there just wasn't
something right about the writing
just
not a bad movie just
it just wasn't right
i mean fury road has to be one of my
favorite films of the last
several years yeah
we saw it six times in the theater and
we bought it on blu-ray and we've
watched it another probably six or seven
times since then
that's an amazing [ __ ] movie amazing
yeah they should teach that in schools
maybe they do already
like i said that to me that distills the
principle of show don't tell yeah
that's one of the best examples of it
yeah let's talk all this plot like going
on and nobody talks
that's [ __ ] great dude you doing good
you all right dj maniac says when people
[ __ ] with me now i threatened to [ __ ]
their dad and give him the son he always
wanted oh [ __ ] which is horrifying when
you realize i'm a straight dude
[Laughter]
that's pretty good i'm gonna have to
remember that one i'm gonna have to
remember that one i don't have a dick
and i'll remember that one look at poop
what is she doing she's here your face
is
you okay
she's like i don't know i'm kind of
worried why is everybody looking at me
okay she was like laying over that
that's her favorite chair yeah
she's laying over there and she's that
we both turned around and looked at her
and she's like am i am i doing something
wrong or
then she gets up and she's like well i
don't know what i'm supposed to be doing
yeah tyler the guy said that thunder
girl felt like it was kind of aimed a
little bit more towards kids i think it
kind of was yeah
or or a family like or like more like a
general
family general audience it wasn't it
wasn't really that right
it wasn't bad but it wasn't great either
yeah but it left tina turner in it she
was yeah she was the best part of it but
it had some strong points to it but it
had it had weak points too it just
yeah it's not bad it's just not
the mix wasn't right
it's just not my favorite of all that
it's kind of like that's what happens
when you take something that was like
this indie
yeah kind of like low budget kind of
[ __ ] that everybody was super into and
you try to
make it to for a general make it for a
general audience and it's like
i just i don't know i just kind of feel
like maybe
and i i'm i like
nowadays because i kind of feel like
everybody understands that like look
there's only certain audiences for
certain things yeah everybody's not
gonna like
everything
so the more you try to make something
for everybody the more nobody is going
to want to see it because it's just
going to be like watered down nonsense
yeah
so
honestly i think the way to go is just
[ __ ] find your niche and like [ __ ]
hit that [ __ ] hard yeah that's basically
all you can do
don't try to make don't try to please
everybody because you're not going to
you just can't how long we've been um
streaming for an hour and a half okay
i've been on for an hour and a half of
people
yeah we may not be on forever
wow shocker yeah
[Laughter]
if you all want to send jenny a super
chat now be the time
what's up fool
what's up thomas not participating
[Laughter]
i'm not here right now well because i
might come back into it in a minute my
[ __ ] head might you need some cocaine
or something i need some cocaine
i need cocaine tom needs a cocaine yeah
she's looking cookies like i don't know
where i can get cocaine at this time of
day
yeah i was out doing my whole thing
today
[Laughter]
uh what's going on tonight
on friday i don't know not that good
well like i said we gotta go we gotta go
see the show tomorrow yeah we are going
to will's pub in orlando to see a starry
night
when was the last time we saw them it's
been a while
yeah been a while yeah i had for you
know what i feel bad but i've like
forgotten even though i you know
i kind of knew about it because i'd done
like the [ __ ] posters and [ __ ] but
i forgot about it until amani messaged
me yeah and said hey are you going to
the starry night show on the 19th and i
was just kind of like uh
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i guess so yeah so
monty's going so we haven't seen her in
a long time so it'll be nice
but
i don't know we'll see how it goes we'll
see how it goes i like wolf's pub it's a
good uh it's a good venue it's been
there for like a million years very
venerable
orlando kind of like uh thing
but
man
i can't believe how [ __ ] drunk it's
like it's not even dark outside
i mean i know it's daylight savings time
so
i'm giving some like leeway but
it's still light out
and he's just like already
oh i'm so drunk
jesus christ
killed an hba says oh tom's trying to
get antsy yeah he's getting fussy that's
what i that's what i say
he's getting fussy
so uh
okay
let me let me talk about
here's the thing that i found on toby
that
um
i don't know if you guys have seen this
around i don't know where it originated
from i don't know where this [ __ ]
show came from
but i'm obsessed with it
like i said i've mentioned it before
it's called bizarre murders
and i've been like watching the
episode's only like 23 28 minutes long
so i've been watching like one or two of
them
whenever i don't have anything there's
only like 52 53 episodes i'm almost like
i think i only have two more
and i was watching
this one last night
the one last night
was from i don't know what the real case
behind this is i'd have to look it up
the one last night was from 1970 because
you guys were talking about led zeppelin
and like [ __ ] like that earlier
this is from 1970 it happened in san
francisco
and it was like
all hippy stuff right
and there was this guy
that was like an artist
uh he was not a very good artist but he
thought he was a great artist so he's
one of those
and he killed this girl
because
he was so obsessed with her
that he couldn't draw anything else
other than her
and so he kept like creeping on her and
after a while she was like dude like
[ __ ] off it's like i have a life to live
can you like not be up in my face like
drawing me 24 7.
and so he decided well if i'm gonna be a
great artist and i'm gonna be able to
draw anything else i'm gonna have to
kill her because that makes complete
sense
so he
bludgeons
who he thinks is this girl to death with
a lava lamp which is the most hippie ass
thing i can think of
in a house full like a co-op house full
of like other hippies who were high as
[ __ ] and had no idea what was going on
problem was
that he actually ended up killing that
girl not the girl that he was obsessed
with but he ended up killing that girl's
sister who also lived there and they
looked a lot alike
and he wasn't really paying attention
obviously
and so
he killed her and then like they bring
him in finally
and he's insistent
i love that he like admitted to the
murder without like seeming to realize
that he was like no i killed this other
girl and they were like no
you killed this girl and he's like no
for real i killed the other one they're
like no you killed this other one
bludgeon death with a [ __ ] lava lamp
that might be the only time that that
ever happened
another one and i think i mentioned this
on uh some of the
comments before
one of the ones that fascinates me it
always like female serial killers
fascinate me because
like i said they tend to have different
motives than male serial killers
these two were really fascinating
because they were just really
um
pragmatic let's call it that
and just like completely like
bloodthirsty
it was two old ladies
and they were at a like a rest home like
a nice rest home like a super expensive
one you know what i mean like one of
those really fancy resort style ones
and i guess they were like [ __ ] bored
or they didn't have enough money or
whatever so they decided that what they
were gonna do
they got together
and they're like okay well we're gonna
go like and volunteer
down at this homeless uh shelter where
they're like feeding homeless people
and then we're going to like target
particular homeless people that seem
like they don't have any
relatives to check on them and we're
gonna take that homeless person
and we're going to say to them
oh you're this big talented person or
whatever uh come with us and we will put
you up in an apartment and we'll pay
your rent and we'll buy you food and
we'll do all this other stuff which most
people that were homeless are like okay
that sounds good to me
even though giant red flag
i mean but you know it's two old ladies
so they do that
and then what they do is that they
they're like okay well um now we put you
in this apartment and stuff just sign
this paper right you don't read it or
anything
um so the people sign the paper then
they wait two years because it was a
life insurance policy and that's how
long it took to mature so they had to
wait two years before they killed the
person
so they would do that and then they
would go rent a car
drug the homeless person
put them in an alley and then run them
over with the rented car so it looked
like an accident
and then they would collect
the life insurance two little old ladies
were doing this [ __ ] damn
you can't [ __ ] trust anybody like i
said
[ __ ] crazy because those little
little ladies did it you can't trust
anybody now anybody but you don't know
yeah i can tell
i can tell i'm not trying to i can sense
it
i can sense it in a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i can't if i come across some old ladies
and i'll [ __ ] be sensitive nah [ __ ]
y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] you tom's gonna punch
that old lady like [ __ ] you hoes i could
tell
[Laughter]
yeah i can tell well the thing about it
is that i mean at least they were smart
enough to like well we have to like
target really vulnerable people which is
like super shitty but yeah like i said
you you go to a homeless person that's
been sleeping in a [ __ ] alley
and said hey we're gonna put you in an
apartment
and you know give you food and stuff
yeah all you have to do is sign this
thing most people are probably not going
to question it too hard even though it
sounds pretty weird yeah
so it's just kind of like you know
remember that case we were talking about
on wednesday night where
that the dude would like be like hey can
you sign this blank piece of paper
thanks
you know what i mean like it's
if somebody asked me hey sign this blank
piece of paper i'd be like absolutely
not
but
they target people that
need help you know what i mean he would
target women at like women's shelters
with kids and stuff it's like that were
homeless or you know didn't have any
money and [ __ ] like that and he's like
promising them oh i'll get you a place
to live and i'll help you out blah blah
that's all you have to do is just sign
your name on this blank piece of paper
it sounds like not that big a deal but
you can ask granters don't do that grab
this you'd be able to see that one
coming i wouldn't you thought so i could
see it coming i believe i could be able
to see it coming
well don't get too cocky though because
don't get too cocky
because the more cocky you get yeah then
the more people can take advantage of
you because you think you know
everything
so i'm always kind of like
i think it's good to like keep a good
balance about that's kind of [ __ ] all
right and just not trust anybody what do
you say about it pope
what do you say about it she's licking
her feet
stop licking your feet
camp guy said there was a real lady in
california
they got old folks to sign over their
social security checks for rent and food
she killed and buried several in her
backyard kept cashing their checks i
kind of feel like once people get to a
certain age i know that serial killers
in general tend to be
younger males
but
there have been some that were like
older people they probably get to a
certain age they're just like [ __ ] it
even if they put me in prison and so i'm
gonna die soon anyway yeah so it's like
i might as well like [ __ ] get some
people to sign over like a million
dollar life insurance policy and then
just like whack them in the head and
like bury them on my pig farm well
they're thinking well all they could do
is give me life
that's what i'm saying life is like five
years
not saying that i might not go like that
because i might
[Laughter]
be like i'm just like i'm just kidding i
wouldn't you'd be like well life is like
five years say [ __ ]
10 years
i couldn't kill an innocent person i
just couldn't yeah it's just a dick move
i mean i could kill a shitty person
yeah that was like you know what i mean
yeah trying to [ __ ] you over or
something yeah yeah i could kill a [ __ ]
most people can't they don't want to
admit it though
but most most people just some random
ass
that didn't do anything some random ass
person didn't do anything to me yeah
most people most people will defend
themselves
but most people will call the cops first
that's the easiest way
well yeah i mean you know you don't know
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen with the
situation it is the safest option yeah
but
i don't know i do kind of feel like
seriously
you're really being this way i'm tired
you're really being this way all right
what time is it we haven't even been
over two hours
two hours is a long time
it's not though okay i'ma see her
i'll sit here i'll see her right i'll
share a ride with you
you're not like you're not pretty you
don't have any wigs you don't have any
like [ __ ] fun [ __ ]
you're not being funny she's saying i'm
not good enough for the show right now
that's right
well i mean you're not being your usual
fun self i guess because you already
like drank a bunch before you got here
and you just like probably parked don't
give a [ __ ] barley apparently no but
it's like i like the friday night it's
not that i don't give a [ __ ] i'm just
tired i'm just tired
[ __ ] i'm always tired i know and yet i
still do the show yeah no suck it up
holy [ __ ] i woke up at 4 30 this morning
and couldn't go back to sleep and then i
was just like well [ __ ] it i'm just
getting up so i just got up
yeah
because i couldn't sleep anymore i got
up at 4 30 because i had to go to the
bathroom it's okay i'll thumbs up the
stream that i'd do that well thank you
more people should do that thumb it up
i'm not going to say smash that like
button but you know
dj maniac says the lava lamp isn't as
hippy as you think i still have a
vintage one i use daily i had one
for a long time that i actually got from
my grandparents house
and
i don't know what happened to it what
the [ __ ] happened to that i used to i
had it in my old house
i don't know if it got thrown out or
like when i divorced my husband i don't
know if it got if he threw it out i
don't know what happened to it
yeah it was like an old like a heavy one
because i feel like they have they
started making them again like in the
80s and 90s because it was like a
resurgence but those were like lighter
they were like made of plastic and [ __ ]
like that but the old ones were like
metal and they were like super heavy so
i could see how you could
like bludgeon someone adapted that
when i saw that show last night i was
like oh yeah
that one i had that lava lamp i had you
could totally kill somebody with that it
was like super heavy yeah dorothea
puente that's right i've heard that name
up to 15 victims
see that's the thing i kind of feel like
and we've talked about this before i
kind of feel like
female serial killers
um
they have like practical motives
they will kill people for
monetary reasons
or they will kill people for like weird
um
like i want to get attention like uh
munchausen by proxy kind of reasons
or well no no that's what i'm saying
those are two categories those are two
separate categories that's what i'm
saying
um so they tend to kill people they know
like family members
um people that they perceive have [ __ ]
them over or people they're gonna get
something out of i don't there's very
very rare for
female serial killers to have like a
sexual motive
like a lot of times male serial killers
not always but a lot of male serial
killers do but female kill serial
killers hardly ever it's pretty much
always have sex have sexual motives
their female serial killers usually
it's two reasons either they want money
or it's practical or
um it's kind of a case where it's like
uh an emotional like a family situation
like somebody [ __ ] them over uh it's
jealousy it's like it's family [ __ ] or
it's like they're killing their kids or
some weird [ __ ] up [ __ ] like that
but it's only those two things you don't
really see a lot of sexual motive with
female serial killers not you know
there's exceptions but not usually
women don't usually get off on that
on killing other people
like the same way that male serial
killers do because you know how a lot of
male serial killers not all of them but
some of them have that weird thing where
it's like
they
they get sexually aroused by like
watching people like having power over
somebody and like watching them suffer
and [ __ ] like that women don't
usually have that
um it's very very rare for
for a female server killer to have that
some people say alienware knows but
i don't know she i don't think she got
any like sexual
i don't think she got a sexual charge
out of that
i don't think it really didn't seem like
it she seemed like she was kind of
[ __ ] up and she was just like getting
revenge
on people as a whole because she was
angry
i don't really got i never got the sense
that she had got a sexual
charge out of it you know what i mean
did anybody i don't know they're trying
to get me dressed up like nosferatu i'm
not gonna get dressed up like nos
tyler the guy says the way i see it if
some [ __ ] decides they have the right
to try and end your life you definitely
have the right to reciprocate oh yeah i
agree
uh holy barrage of tomb says human
beings are a virus with shoes
billy except comedian
r.i.p
yeah it's the 100th anniversary of
nosferatu holy [ __ ] isn't that crazy
that's crazy because i still really like
a lot of those silent movies and it
never i mean it occurs to me that
they're more than 100 years old but
i don't know
in another way it doesn't really occur
to you because like a lot of [ __ ] hasn't
a lot of shit's changed but a lot of
[ __ ] hasn't changed also
holy parish of doom says my wife watches
crime shows and i'm always surprised at
how many women are the killers yeah and
one thing that i will say about the
bizarre murder show that i was watching
i don't know how old it is
but
they did seem to do like a good mix
of male and female killers
but like i said even on that show
usually the women that killed people
were like there was one woman on there
that was um
she was like a black widow type thing
where she would like marry somebody
and then after a couple years she'd like
get sick of them and then be like well
i'm gonna need some life insurance out
of this [ __ ] and then she would
like you know poison them or or what she
did in this case was she said that um
that an intruder had broken in or no she
paid an intruder to break in but the
intruder [ __ ] it up and didn't kill
the guy so then she's like well [ __ ] it
i have to do it myself so then she
waited a little while
and then
made it like it was in it like he had
attacked like the husband had had
attacked her and then she had to shoot
him like in self-defense and uh they
fell for it for like three it was a
small town and everybody knew her
so
she actually got away with it for
three or four years they only caught her
because
she married again
and then she kind of tried to do it
again to her new husband which
that's probably not a great idea i mean
if you're gonna do that at least like
[ __ ] move
so they don't like no so you don't have
a history but yeah so then they were
kind of like okay well maybe you did
that [ __ ] up [ __ ] with the first but
she got away with it for uh for a while
uh camp guy said females use poison at
way higher rates than men yeah they do
they ten i mean
like i said it just tends to be
it's just different motivations it's
just a completely different motivation
i'm not saying that dudes don't like
kill people for
insurance and [ __ ] like that because
obviously they do
but
serial killers
you tend to see like when you see female
serial killers they tend to be like
angels of mercy type killers i'm gonna
go around like poisoning all these like
people in this hospital where i'm a
nurse because that gives them some weird
like sense of power
they'll do that
or
you know they'll kill people just for
money
like these old ladies like running over
bombs
for our homeless people for their
[ __ ]
you know what i mean
uh camp guy said i saw a real interview
with uh warnos shortly before she was
executed she was paranoid schizophrenic
uh you could tell she was really crazy
yeah she um
she had some problems
she had some problems
um so
she's kind of i know a lot of people
like point her out oh they're like a
female serial killer that's like a male
serial killer but she wasn't like a male
series no she wasn't not really
they're getting a creepy phone again
hi pokey why are you mad why are you
making that [ __ ] man
she made me she made mad eyes for a
second but yeah she wasn't really like a
male serial killer at all like i said
she didn't really seem to get any like
sexual or emotional like enjoyment
necessarily out of killing the people
she just shot them she didn't like
torture them or nothing a serial killer
is a [ __ ] serial rapist it's the same
thing
they just happen to kill the victim
sometimes get get they get into killing
the victim but it's their serial rapist
and women aren't serial rapists so
that's why you're just not gonna find
serial killers in the same way
i think waronos wasn't a serial rapist
so she wasn't really a true serial
killer
yeah like not and not in the definition
where like if you're talking about
somebody like ted bundy or somebody like
that that had like some kind of she was
a different anomaly she was more like a
[ __ ]
serial robber who was murdering people
not really a serial rapist
yeah
that's what i mean she didn't really
seem to have any kind of like yeah she
was she had uh mental issues for sure
but she didn't really seem like the way
that male c or serial killers seem to
have these weird like paraphilias where
they're kind of like
like btk it's like oh i like to dress up
in ladies clothes and like lay in
[ __ ]
graves and [ __ ] like that she didn't
have any weird
sexual [ __ ] she was just kind of like
this dude like pissed me off
so i shot him
part of the problem is language language
and legal definitions
when you say
serial killer you think of somebody who
just kills a bunch of people
that's
because of the problem with linguistics
that's not what serial killers are
they're serial rapists they just have to
kill the victim
and
so they're going to have a certain kind
of personality
women in general are not serial rapists
not not ones like these uh so
yeah you don't really you're not gonna
lie in that same deal now
there's a difference between
what you would call a serial killer and
let's say like a mass murderer
which is somebody who kills somebody in
a big [ __ ] attack that's totally
different situation
or somebody who's uh
say kind of like a [ __ ] world war two
[ __ ] expert sniper that's not a
serial killer it's just it's just a
different or somebody who's like the
[ __ ] red baron who [ __ ] shoots
down other [ __ ] pilots it's not a
serial killer a serial killer as you
know it what you're thinking of is a
serial rapist
they just happen to kill the victim
and it doesn't necessarily mean like
actual rape yeah but that's what's in
their mind it's some kind of like like i
said like some kind of like paraphilia
yeah this is this is a sexual
orientation like being gay or straight
or something
this is this is what this is this is a
sexual orientation
where their sexual orientation and
fantasies about murder have have merged
and their fantasies about rape and
there's a couple different versions of
them there's kind of like power rapists
and
who are into making the [ __ ] victim
feel frightened and then there are other
ones that are big into [ __ ] torture
and then there's other ones that aren't
into that at all
like jeffrey dahmer wasn't into that at
all he just wanted to [ __ ] make a sex
slave
yeah he just wanted somebody that was
really passive
yeah so
they weren't really but again it was a
sexual paradigm yeah it's awesome it
wasn't yeah
you don't see that as much with fema
right i can't really think it's some
kind of i'm sure there's one but i can't
really think of like a female
serial killer in that sense i just
serious one i don't i can't think of one
i mean there might be but i can't think
of one off hand well what's weird is
that you'll have a male serial killer
who might have a girlfriend who's kind
of like a satellite to this
yeah
we've done shows about like couples yeah
but it usually but i always kind of say
and i think i've said this on the shows
if that
woman didn't hook up with that dude
would she have done that [ __ ] probably
not no probably not even though the
women that have survived those couples
said that the woman was worse but we
don't really know what it was was she
the woman acting out
[ __ ] something to try to impress the
male i think yeah i think that's exactly
what it is or was it anger that the male
was more interested in that that too so
it's kind of like a jealousy thing yeah
that too i think those are both uh both
at play but like i said if those factors
weren't at play
i don't think she would have done that
[ __ ] on her own no but it's just funny
to think that woman's sexuality can be
morphed into something so extreme in
some cases it's weird
but the thing about it is that it seems
like the male sexuality is already that
extreme yeah
and so it's it's always like yeah so
it's always like surprising when a woman
does it yeah
but we like it it's bad because it's all
it's almost kind of like we expect we
don't expect any better
from men i guess i think i don't think
that's what it is i think what it is is
that the dude's [ __ ] far far out in
the overton window
in terms of [ __ ] he's already in
these extreme levels
and you show it to a woman and somehow
she responds to it positively
kind of like
taking somebody to go see
gladiatorial combat in the arena
in [ __ ] ancient realm they said the
same thing that people would be against
all that stuff until they went to the
arena and saw these guys fighting it out
and they would get kind of emotionally
wrapped up into watching this
fight for survival and then they would
get addicted to it so i think it was
kind of like that
it might be too it might be a situation
where
because i kind of feel like this
heightened emotion yeah it means this
woman psyched up and yeah and somehow
sucked into it
and then she sees this woman killed and
it's some kind of weird
emotional high off of it and then she's
[ __ ] like well i survived it and this
dude who did it he loves me some kind of
weird
extreme yeah i think that's probably
what it is and honestly like i said i
kind of feel like if left to their own
devices
99 of women would not do anything like
that if left to their own devices no um
but if you have somebody like um
you know like [ __ ] uh myra hindley
for example like the one of the moore's
murderers had she never met ian brady
i do not think she would have done
anything i mean they killed children
yeah
do i think she would have killed
children had she never met him no
absolutely not some kind of synergy
absolutely not but
the thing about it though it's kind of
like that frog and boiling water thing
it's like sometimes
a woman with particular
weaknesses particular insecurities
particular proclivities perhaps
they meet exactly the wrong
person
and that person is able to
not consciously but they're able to kind
of like pinpoint
those weaknesses those insecurities
and
the more the longer they're together
um there's this thing where she's like
like you said she wants to like impress
him now like he's kind of like going
farther and farther out there and she's
like oh well i want him to like me i
want him to love me
so i have to do this that the other so i
have to follow him like follow his lead
where he's going and sometimes that's
not
and if she doesn't really have a really
good sense of herself or a sense of
um
right and wrong she might like not
immediately twig onto the fact that this
is really bad like this path that you're
on is leading to like something really
bad and she might not be she might not
have the wherewithal to like get the
[ __ ] out of it in time i think i think
it being wrong is where a lot of this is
coming from though they're doing
something that's wrong and that's
heightening the [ __ ] thing there's
another there was another [ __ ] case
where
it was two lesbian chicks
who were really into this other girl who
was like a straight girl who didn't get
any attention that they converted over
and they were fighting over her and that
[ __ ] went on for a long time
and eventually the two girls
were fighting over this straight girl
and they were teenagers
they [ __ ] were torturing her and
stuff and the [ __ ]
um they tortured her over a period of a
couple days for being a cheat or
something
i don't remember exactly what it was but
then they had her in a trunk of a car
and set her on fire
remember that one that was back in the
late 80s early 90s
so it's not just a
male thing
oh it's absolutely not um lesbian
females actually were doing the same
kind of well straight females do that
kind of [ __ ] too if
given the right circumstances right
i kind of feel like the thing about it
is that
i kind of feel like a lot of women not
all of them but generally i think women
if the right circumstances aren't
presented then they won't go down that
route right they'll just be like quote
unquote normal
but if they meet the wrong person or if
they get like sucked up in the wrong
situation
um they'll allow themselves to go along
with it because maybe deep down they
kind of want to do that but they didn't
really have the quote-unquote balls to
do it until someone else
i guess gave them license and said oh
it's okay
or you know i'm doing it too so it's
fine you know what i mean it's almost
kind of like giving them permission so i
kind of feel like there's that aspect
too
tyler the guy says i feel like the
difference between female killers and
male killers is that a lot of the time
it feels like the females see it as
nothing personal because they'll use
quicker cleaner methods yeah i kind of
feel like the the women
seem like generally not always they seem
like they're not enjoying the killing
itself the killing is just like a means
to an end that's what i mean by women
generally being more practical serial
killers in the sense that you want
something from this person being dead
you're not enjoying the
process of killing them well they do
have some as as some men do they do have
some weird girls they have one little
girl who's running around
cutting little boys dicks off and
strangling to death
they caught her though before remember
that remember her
who the little girl mary bell yeah she
was a little girl and she was she was
10. she's ten she was cutting off little
boys dicks and [ __ ] strangling to
death i thought we did a show about her
did we
yeah but they caught her before she got
old i don't know what it did to her
she killed two or three though
i wanted to do a show about that i don't
remember if we did that i talked about
this earlier
it's weird that this was going on a lot
in the 60s and the 70s but then it just
kind of in the 80s it started to trail
off
and
i thought that [ __ ] was weird
and i mentioned something about it on
the show and then later on people
started to confirm it
i kind of had this theory that it might
have had something to do with unleaded
gasoline or leaded gasoline
and then other people came out and said
yeah leaded gasoline may have had
something to do with it that is
absolutely a factor you see
the ancient romans all right you talking
did weird ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] that really didn't seem to make any
sense
and it was only the rich people that
were mostly the rich people that were
doing this
in ancient rome
well
one of the things that the rich people
all had in common with each other is
that they had
water they had running water in their
houses
and the pipes were made out of lead
and they ate and rich people ate off of
lead plates
they even could afford to season their
food
and one of the seasonings that they used
was lead
lead is a heavy metal it's toxic it'll
give you [ __ ] brain damage it's like
it's like [ __ ] swallowing mercury
make you crazy
tends to make you violent and lowers
inhibitions
um
well
back in the day
they for some reason somebody decided it
was a good idea to put lead particles
inside of gasoline because it made
valves
in the [ __ ] engine head
made them quiet you know when they would
open and close
and would help with [ __ ] valve
sealing
so during the time of the serial killer
you'll notice that
they're they're burning leaded gasoline
and it's in a time when cities are
starting to
get pretty big in the united states
and if you look
the places where serial murderers are
happening tend to be kind of populated
areas
in a place where
these lead particles might be building
up
so i was just thinking i was like man
[ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] these people do it almost
sounds like what the romans were doing
with this [ __ ] lead poisoning
and i was thinking about that blooded
gasoline and yeah i want to say i'm a
genius but you know i'm a genius
i'm [ __ ] thinking i wonder if that
letted gasoline have anything to do with
it
well jenny looked into it and she found
out that she that i wasn't the only
person that thought of that
that they had some people that were
seriously considering
you know these so-called educated people
these so-called educated people had also
figured out that yeah that was around
the time when lead
particles
pry would have been
building up in these
urban areas and people were breathing
that
which yeah that might make you crazy
i could see it it might make you crazy
well like i said the more i look into it
like i said i don't think it's the major
factor but i think it was a significant
factor it's not a contributing factor
i mean there was a reason why
i mean the 60s and 70s and to some
extent the 80s were like the heyday of
the
serial killer at least the serial killer
especially the perceived area sure
where it was [ __ ]
heavily populated
and we've talked a lot about and this is
something that i'm really interested in
is like the whole geographical yeah uh
aspect of serial killing
um how certain cities at certain times
became kind of like hubs
of this kind of activity
for various reasons yeah there's a lot
of gasoline being burned in those areas
over a period of time yeah those
particles are building up in those areas
well the thing too about particularly
southern california at the time was that
a lot of people from everywhere were
like this is a very transient population
and anytime you have a very very large
transient population
you're going to have people preying on
those people because
serial killers are predators so they're
like looking for victims that will
perhaps not be missed
looking for people that
you know are runaways or
sex workers or whatever and you go into
these areas in the 60s maybe you're born
in this area
well those particles have been building
up in there in those areas for decades
wind can't blow those little particles
out of there everywhere blowing them
around a little bit like pieces of
invisible garbage and piling up in
corners
you know what i mean uh
so
by the time the 60s 70s and 80s had
rolled out there's a lot of that lead
built up in those areas
blowing around so that's what i think it
was [ __ ] people up [ __ ] people up
what are you doing you know she was
pulling [ __ ] out of my other [ __ ]
thing she loved all the books i have a
bookshelf right there she's pulling all
the books out of it yeah when we're not
paying attention she goes over there and
like starts pulling books out oh and now
she's gonna tear up the couch you guys
are not paying attention yeah phoenix is
yeah tom you're a genius yeah i'm a
genius [ __ ] right i'm jake
i'm not gonna say i'm not gonna say that
the the lead did it
i thought well i think it's totally
effective i think it was a was a
contributing factor
you have a [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] in
a bad place at a bad time breathing in
all that lead
and it's lowering his inhibitions and
he's more likely now to do something
to act on his fantasies and he's getting
a little more [ __ ]
crazy stop it pook
she's not gonna just just let her those
are those are my old books yeah she can
tear this up that's why i put them on
the bottom because i knew she would tear
them up because it started to trail off
around the time they stopped
selling that leaded gasoline
yeah i kind of feel like the the height
of serial killer activity as far as i
can uh remember was like late 80s yeah
and then like when by the time the 90s
rolled around it was starting to like
decline yeah well that was around the
time of unleaded gas yeah i mean there's
still some around obviously but it's not
like it was it was it's not like it was
you don't have all these [ __ ] traffic
running around blowing that [ __ ] out of
the tailpipe or a banana it's in a tail
pipe
you know they don't have a banana and
tail pipe like they used to
everyone had and it wouldn't it would
not surprise me
that's lead man
make you crazy i mean
everybody knows that lead does
[ __ ] up [ __ ] to your brain yeah gildan
h phoenix says some women are just bad
yeah that's right uh there are some
women who want to do bad but are shy to
try it then when they find the right guy
they set their wild side free oh yeah
now like i said i've said this before
i'm not saying that woman is like good
i'm sure she's like imagined all this
[ __ ] in her head had she not met like i
said myra hindley uh carla hamulka who
like some of the
you know women and the couples that
we've talked about before
i'm always kind of curious had that
woman never met the right quote unquote
wrong man
she would have just maybe had a normal
life and that just had some really
[ __ ] up fantasies or like wrote some
[ __ ] up horror fiction or something
like that
but
would she have ever like killed anybody
like i don't know like i doubt it i
doubt it
i don't think that a lot of women
they don't really have even if they have
like the instinct to like act on it
which a lot of women do
but you wouldn't actually do it
i kind of feel like they need that
dude that's kind of like yeah we're
going to do it it's going to be awesome
but i'll love you forever and blah blah
i kind of feel like they need that extra
thing like to do that [ __ ] i don't think
they would do it on their own just they
wouldn't some kind of weird thing they
would think about it
sure but they wouldn't actually do it
they had a lot of male serial killers
running around doing that kind of [ __ ]
and it's because there was another dude
with them to see it
so that's part of it well yeah that's
another
synergy
yeah
i mean the whole like
honestly that really kind of like
fascinates me the whole like [ __ ]
even what whether it's male female or
whether it's male male
like dudes that went around like serial
killing like together yeah you know what
i mean like [ __ ] hey get each other
wrong
yeah
i can see it more with dudes yeah but i
see the couple dynamic too
you know what i mean and i kind of feel
like it's
it's kind of a thing where
as i mentioned before i think like the
woman gets to a point where it's like
well i have to like i have to like keep
up with him then i have to top him like
i have to impress him right and so
they'll be like worse because you were
talking we were talking about fred and
rosemary west yeah and um somebody
brought that up before camp guy brought
that up
and i was kind of like uh you know
pretty much everybody escaped from them
said that rosemary was worse than him
yeah
um and that might be why i mean i'm not
saying she wasn't a [ __ ] up person i'm
just saying that her
meeting an even more [ __ ] up person
than her
exacerbated her worst tendencies
and so she was gonna go way the [ __ ] out
there and like try to top him yeah she
was doing weird bdsm [ __ ] with her own
sons though they were little boys so she
was crazy too yeah yeah yeah yeah and
i'm not i'm not saying they that these
women don't have problems because
obviously they do
but i'm just saying that if left to
their own devices if they had never met
those dudes would they have done this
[ __ ] of their own volition
most of the time probably not like the
dudes unleashed it yeah
but the problem is that they tend to be
attracted to these types of dudes yeah
and then these dudes kind of like bring
it out of them like bring the worst out
of them and then at that point they're
like oh well now i have license to act
like that so now i'm going to be like
even worse than him yeah because i'm
trying to like be i'm trying to top him
i'm trying to be better so i kind of
feel like there's that kind of like
situation going on too
um
wickedly says i have that nosferatu
poster that's on the wall yeah well
there you go mine is on poster board
it's a german promo from the og release
honestly that is my favorite i think
that's my favorite movie poster that
i've ever owned i've had that since
the early or the no the mid 1990s and i
actually got that my ex-mother-in-law
bought me that for my birthday one year
from in the uk
and uh from some shop in the uk i
remember some horror story
and i'm just like i love that poster
like so much that i love that kind of
like because it's very
it's a little bit art nouveau which i
really like it's an illustration which i
also really like because i don't like a
lot of these movie posters that are like
photos
that's so lame
i like the old school like
movie posters that were like paintings
you know
that's why so many of them like i like
that frankenstein one back there and
[ __ ] like that i like the the paintings
and stuff
uh gilded each finish said women need
that extra testosterone push to do stuff
is that what it is i guess okay so maybe
it's not a good idea to like
testosterone
yeah we'll all become serial killers
like i said we think about it i think
about it plenty oh you think about being
a serial killer no i don't think about
being a serial killer but you but you do
kind of like think about
you know if somebody pisses you off
you're like man i could like tear that
[ __ ] person's head off oh okay and
like you know what i mean yeah because
if you think about being a circuit i'm
gonna get rid of you
[Laughter]
no i'm just saying but everybody has
those thoughts get mad you get mad and
it's like yeah you to like [ __ ] turn
that person inside out i get that
everybody has that yeah um whether you
act on it or not that's a whole
different situation and i kind of feel
like 99 of the time women will not act
on it
unless
there's some other factor at play and
usually it's a dude that's already a
serial killer that's already done that
[ __ ] and he's just like yeah baby it's
okay
i'll love you even more
if you like do some even more [ __ ] up
[ __ ] than me
although i wonder you know what now i'm
wondering can i have another drink yeah
i'm gonna sleep you though oh christ i
am getting sleepy it's not we haven't
gone
we haven't done that long
now i'm kind of wondering
please please somebody tell me if this
is the case because now i'm imagining
that there's a serial killer couple out
there somewhere
where
the dude was like all he's like i'm just
like the freakiest like i'm the worst
serial killer ever and then he finds a
girlfriend and she's like oh yeah i'm
into that and like she starts doing it
too but then she like surpasses him and
she like starts coming up with all this
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that like he never
even thought of
and then i wonder if his ego
is
kind of like if he you know if he gets
kind of like a fragile ego about it
and then he's like well i'm gonna have
to kill this [ __ ] too because now she's
like thinking of better [ __ ] than i was
thinking of and i don't like it
i don't like it so i kind of feel like
maybe
that has to have happened right that has
to have happened
i kind of feel like at some point that
had to have happened
um
jen allen says rose west might be an
exception she committed murder while she
was in jail yeah that's true that's true
she might be
yeah
i mean she's kind of messed up i was
kind of thinking of i watched this other
thing the other day i can't remember
what her name was but
she was kind of one of those ones that
was part of a couple maybe one of you
guys can remember they like can remind
me but she was like part of a couple and
then he had done some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
then she thought she was gonna like
impress him she's like oh i'm gonna kill
this dude that we said we're gonna kill
and then i'm gonna like be in this van
i'm gonna like [ __ ] cut his head off
like with my bare hands and it'll be
like super brutal
and like because she was like trying to
impress them and [ __ ]
and like the dude wasn't there
but
she was just like trying to show him
that that was like something that she
did but i was saying that while you were
gone i said there had to have been some
kind of like dynamic or like a serial
killer couple like the dude was all yeah
like i'm all like [ __ ] up and i do all
this [ __ ] up [ __ ] and then like the
woman came up with all these crazy
[ __ ] ideas that he never thought of
and did way more [ __ ] like [ __ ] up
[ __ ] than him and then he was like
really like kind of intimidated
and like his ego got like all [ __ ]
bruised and stuff because he was like oh
man she's thinking of better [ __ ] than
me so maybe i should like probably like
kill her now so i don't know has that
happened i don't know i kind of feel
like that has to have happened
um mary connolly says there's a new
youtube on all things psychopath goes
over lots of aspect about two hours okay
so i'm gonna have to look that up
um punching someone out maybe but not
killing them yeah it's like honestly i
wouldn't usually well i don't know i
wouldn't usually kill a person it
depends on what they did
because some people
that are walking around in the world
i don't know i kind of feel like maybe
the world would be a better place if
they weren't walking around in the world
i'm not going to kill them it's not my
place but i'm just saying if they just
dropped out of a heart attack or stroke
or something i'm not going to be upset
about it
let's say that
um mary connolly says uh what are they
talking about
oh they're talking about um
come on you need to like [ __ ]
well guilded age killed h fedex says i
kind of like tom don't kill him jenny i
wouldn't kill him she couldn't i mean if
i'm gonna kill somebody i'm gonna i'm
gonna do like the regular i wouldn't do
that but i'm still if i was gonna kill
somebody it would just be like a random
ass stranger because i'm not dumb i'm
not gonna get caught
perhaps all i gotta say is
pepsi zero is not as good as [ __ ] uh
uh coca-cola zero
it's just not
drinking it right now um
is that you at that at the dg yeah the
dg
the dollar general the dollar general
yeah pepsi zero is not as good i will
say that the dr pepper zero is actually
not bad it's good yeah and if anything
it's kind of sweeter than real this
isn't that good dr pepper which is a
little unsettling
um
i like dr i thought it was a little
sweet like i could drink a whole can but
it was a little much
you know what i mean
mike cernicky says uh tom i'm a minimum
wage loser with no education living with
the folks 41 years old should i even
bother with attempting to make something
myself or should i just pack it in and
have fun
dude i'm like 49
and every single day i think to myself
look at how much life have i wasted like
doing this that the other thing
but
then i think to myself you know of some
like famous writers or something like
that that didn't even like publish their
first thing until they were like 50.
so
41
41's yum that's still pretty young i
didn't see you dude um
i had to look at you and go yeah you
don't ever think that you're too old to
do anything
no seriously don't ever think you're too
old to do it you don't know you can
still do anything you don't know how
much longer you're going to live you
could live another [ __ ] like
legitimately you could live another 50
years that's a long time
so
you know do what you got to do never
ever think that you're too old seriously
nowadays
i've seen like some [ __ ] youtubers
that are like 28. oh my god i'm so old
seriously 28. yeah and there's like oh
my god i'm so old i'm like
holy crap i didn't even start
complaining about being too old until i
was at least 40. come on now 28 years
old you think you're old jesus christ
you have like so much [ __ ] life left
i mean like i said it's you
well like we were talking about earlier
and like tom's bumming everybody out
saying boy you could die any time blah
blah blah it's like don't care about
anything but no you could live i could
live another 50 [ __ ] years yeah
that's not crazy if i lived another 50
years i'd be 99
which
like i said my great-grandma lived until
she was 92 and she might still be she
might have lived longer if she hadn't
like killed herself
but so it's not crazy i don't think i'm
going to live that long but you know
what i mean i could
so 41 is still pretty young
i don't really really
feel all that old let me finish let me
finish what i'm gonna
41 still pretty young
uh i haven't seen you i don't know what
your deal is i don't know where you come
from i don't know what your prospects
are i mean i just don't know enough
about you
but 41 is still very young
you can do a lot
in a very short period of time if you're
smart
all right i mean [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] 52 or
53.
i kind of like the way i am now better
than i was at 41.
yeah me too but
i started looking like this my size and
everything relatively recently the past
couple years
because i understood how to do it
it all depends on what it is that you're
trying to do and what it is you want to
do if you don't want to do anything then
just [ __ ] sit sit back and do nothing
but if you want to do something then you
got to figure out how it is how what it
is you have to do to get it done
you know if if you want yourself to look
a certain way
or if you want to look and here's
something else man jenny will [ __ ]
tell you i'll tell you
people do treat you differently people
treat you based on how you look they
just do
and uh sometimes you might have to
change how you look
but that's not a big deal you can work
towards that that's that's possible
you know gain weight lose weight
get bigger get smaller whatever
you know
it's just if you have the discipline and
the money you know you go through the
[ __ ] training to do it you take the
right kind of chemicals or whatever it
is you need and you can do it
so uh well and don't think you have to
do everything like today no it's all
because i kind of feel like that's
i struggle with that too and it's like
i'm constantly at war with myself not so
much about like physical fitness or
anything like that but like other like
doing
projects and stuff and i'm kind of like
man if i can't get this project done
like today or like this week then like
ah it's all over you know what i mean
yeah it's like so it's very so i have to
really really like pace myself
and put things into that was one thing
that i learned a couple years ago that
actually helped me out a lot
break everything down to like tiny small
pieces yeah so i now i do like every day
i get up i have a list what are we doing
today
let's do this this this this little
piece of this
you know just get one
chapter done just get one something done
like get a home page done get something
like that and so then you'll feel like
you're progressing towards something
like don't feel like you have to do
everything in one day because i have
that problem brian manowicz is a friend
of mine you might know him as a vegan
black metal chef he's been on television
[ __ ]
and uh brian was like
he's a rad dude by the way
yeah he's vegan
yes and he's also getting into
bodybuilding and stuff and
i saw him last week
at the club and i said you're getting
bigger brian because oh thanks man
thanks
he's a little he's getting a little bit
bigger okay
he's looking pretty good he's a little
bit younger than me probably about how
much maybe not ten years but maybe about
seven seven how old he is probably six
seven eight years younger than me maybe
and uh
he was like yeah man [ __ ] you know
thanks for saying so you're you're the
biggest guy i know and i
it kind of
struck me i was like i'm the biggest guy
you know and i was like i'm looking
around because man you you don't nobody
here looks like you
and i'm looking around in a club and i'm
realizing yeah i guess nobody looks like
me
but you see i don't see myself the way
other people see me because it was a
slow process
and it
it didn't take that long
you know it took about
you can go back and look at the videos
it's all archived right here about two
years
well about three years probably
i started i started training about three
years ago
and uh
i probably could have speeded it up had
i jumped on gear a lot earlier and
[ __ ] done higher doses but that's not
what my goal was
my goal was health and to make like a
slow trans transformation
so
but
at 41 a lot is [ __ ] possible
[ __ ] if you're to make me 41 i feel like
a young man i'd be doing all kinds of
great [ __ ] yeah that's still pretty
young
i mean like i said i divorced when i was
38 yeah and had a whole like [ __ ]
resurgence right you know what i mean
where i was like dating again and i was
like clubbing and [ __ ] like that so 41
like does not really seem that cold
to me so
holy parachute
brings up yeah i saw that uh brings up
something interesting it's interesting
that people view life in terms of doing
something i think much of that is merely
an offshoot of consumer capitalist
system of values yeah i get what you're
saying like most people equate doing
something with your life with making
money
and
yeah i get what you're saying like what
i'm saying though is that
my thing
is that i feel like
when i was younger i feel like i spent
so much my time like i had so many ideas
like i wanted to do all this stuff but i
had like these weird
mental things where i kind of felt like
well whatever i do like if i wrote a
story it wasn't good enough or it's like
nothing was ever
good enough like i don't want to send it
to a publisher it's not good enough um
you know if i did artwork it's not good
enough so
i spent like i kind of feel like i spent
the first half of my life
not
like doing stuff but not like trying to
do anything more with it because i felt
like it wasn't good enough or it wasn't
good as other people's stuff
so
i kind of feel like my whole entire like
late 30s and early 40s was trying to get
past that
mindset
so nowadays i'm kind of feel like yes i
have to make money because
obviously i have bills to pay
and
you know i'm i'm a freelancer i have
like three or four different gigs going
right now this show is one i have
graphic design i have books i have stuff
like that so it's like i'm always kind
of like struggling to make enough money
to pay bills
but honestly if somebody handed me a
million dollars tomorrow
i would still do [ __ ] just because i
want to do [ __ ] so it's not so much that
i wanna like i wanna make money
obviously but
if i had money
and i was just like and i could just do
whatever i wanted
i would still do like creative [ __ ]
because
i like to and that's just kind of like
that's what i enjoy and that's what i
would want to do so i don't
you know what i mean i'm just saying
that
so it's not so much about making money
but i do kind of get
i do kind of get it mike zarnicki has uh
sacramento has the worst of the worst
uh and he's like yeah dorothea pointe we
talked about that i would do a show on
richard chase vampire said we did do a
show about him we did a show about
we did a show i think it was about
vampire killers in general so it was
richard chase and it was that that [ __ ]
nut that was [ __ ]
what that what the [ __ ] was that dude's
name i don't know
what dude
the dude that like your friend
uh was their lawyer
what was that what was that kid's name
yeah the vampire cult yeah visago there
oh yeah
what was it about the saga what was this
real name was his real name
the vampire killer yeah we did a whole
vampire killer show richard chase was on
there it was a while back but i don't
remember what it was yeah yeah yeah dj
said she's a client yeah you did half a
show on chase yeah he's worth at least
three hours yeah yeah
um mike starkey says you guys have the
relationship i want really good friends
that live together
yeah i mean you know
it's kind of like it's
it's what it's not perfect i mean
nothing's perfect well nothing is yes
we're humans yeah so you don't want to
idealize everything
it's just uh and then somebody's in
there saying that it was all just tom's
a hormone kings it's all about hormones
no it's not
yeah your hormonal profile is the key
that's the basis for all [ __ ]
healthy living if you have that
there's a lot of stuff you can do on top
of that
so it's not just that it's a bunch of
stuff
but i found out that
it's just dealing with a lot of people
most people don't have what it takes to
even [ __ ] want the knowledge or to
know to do any of this
you also have to work out
you know
and you got to put out
at least 80 percent
most people can't put out 30 percent you
know but you got to put about 70 80
and you'll [ __ ] hold together you put
out 90 95 you'll [ __ ] grow even
stronger
but most people aren't like that they
just want an easy life and they just
like you want to sit back and fat get
fat and eat and
[ __ ] yeah i wish i could do that but
i just didn't want to do anything i
gotta get on my [ __ ] bike and sweat
yeah every single day
i hate it we got friends that'll [ __ ]
still gotta do it i've hooked friends up
i said look take this and this and this
you'll be fine but you have to do this
and that
they they won't work out
so
none of that means anything oh it
doesn't work well it doesn't work
because you sit around any [ __ ]
donuts well everybody wants they want
something for nothing for nothing yeah
it's like look i would love it yeah look
if you press a button honestly if you
could pop my brain
into like a robot avatar
and i could just like eat and enjoy
whatever food i wanted and didn't get
that they would do i would totally do
that yeah not gonna lie right um
but
the fact is i wish i could do that i
wish i could just like sit around and
like eat donuts and stuff but i can't
yeah i can't so i don't so a lot of
people
even most people will say they want to
look a certain way but they'll never
they'll never do what it takes
some of them will [ __ ] buy this [ __ ]
they'll buy steroids or something
and hormones and they'll shoot them up
they don't do anything and nothing
happens and they go that didn't work
that's awful it's because you didn't do
anything
okay
that's why a lot of dudes will [ __ ]
take steroids and [ __ ] those hormones
they won't tell me but they're doing it
because other people go well you just
look like that because you're on
steroids
no no
[ __ ]
it's everything you know i mean you're
diminishing the work [ __ ]
to look that way you have to eat a
certain way you have to [ __ ] lift a
lot of weight to work out and you have
to take all that stuff
um
you just can't sit around take steroids
and get big
no nothing i'm just saying that every
individual yeah has to come to like
a thing and this is it's taken me almost
50 years to come to this place like what
do you want out of life yeah like what
do you enjoy
and you have to like maximize what you
enjoy right and minimize what you don't
enjoy
um as much as you can like i understand
that everybody obviously like i said
everybody got to make money
so you can't like minimize it's like oh
i don't want to go to work anymore yeah
that's not going to work out if you got
like [ __ ] bills to pay i get it
because i [ __ ] hate working too
but
you know you have to just like kind of
come to a balance that you can like
[ __ ] live with
and
that's all you have to do
um i love this mary connolly says when
i'm down i read like the night by eli
weissel or watch schindler's list and
damn my life is great in comparison
honestly i kind of feel like this is
something that people don't understand a
lot about goths and stuff like that
um
watching miserable [ __ ] or listening to
like miserable sounding music or what
people would uh would categorize this
miserable sounding music that's not
miserable to us because
you are listening to or watching
somebody
that is perhaps
um
worse off than you are
and so
that's making you feel better by
comparison which is like well
at least my life isn't as bad as this
person's life you know what i mean yeah
i kind of feel like that's
kind of the appeal of horror movies too
you're kind of like well my life kind of
sucks but then you watch the hormones
like well
it could be a lot worse though look at
that kind of look at that [ __ ] so
so there's that too that's that's why
it's kind of like a happy [ __ ] it's
it's happy
um man what yeah storm yeah i know
strong come
strong storm coming
get with it tom it's friday i'm here i'm
here
i already hold on
are you yeah i'm gonna make it
camp guy said exactly what my guitar
teacher told me i was happy that i
practiced 25 to 30 minutes a day that
week he said you wouldn't believe how
good you would get if you played an hour
or more every day well like i said it's
all like a balance like you have to kind
of like ask yourself
what do you want out of life
um
[Music]
you know what would make you happy
and what can you do every day
to maximize that which would make you
happy
you have to do that and like minimize
that which would like make you depressed
to whatever degree you can do that
because like i said
you know we can't all do that obviously
because we all have to make money to
live and [ __ ] like that so
you just have to do that is this what
you want to do
um
then you have to put the work in and you
have to put the work in like everybody
do it and the money
well like i said um you know i'm real
into
doing like creative [ __ ]
uh so it's like i kind of like do i i
want to write this book i want to like
you know make this website i want to
like make this game or whatever and it's
like how much
time or are you willing to put into that
um
will it make you money not necessarily
but it's like will it make me happy yeah
um
i kind of like judge it as
what do i look forward to doing when i'm
done with all the [ __ ] that i don't
really want to do like to make money you
know what i'm saying
it's kind of that because i always kind
of like i get up and i'm just like okay
we'll have to do this that and the other
thing to make x amount of dollars and
then after that's done
what am i looking forward to doing
you know
yeah whatever you're looking forward to
doing
that's what you want to do
me like i said that's usually writing
books designing games
you know doing horror kind of [ __ ]
so
that's what i want to do does it make
money not necessarily but that's what
makes me happy though
so i do try to like
put that into my day
so i'm not
constantly
although i kind of feel like i'm still
constantly like [ __ ]
i don't know i feel like i'm still
constantly like always doing like other
people's [ __ ] yeah see this chick here
they got women that want to look like
that
that's patricia alamo
okay
she's a short little muscle girl all
right
the thing is oh yeah i'd like to look
like that
but if you saw that that girl probably
spent 200 a [ __ ] month
just on [ __ ]
hormones and [ __ ]
steroids and [ __ ] like that and training
most people go oh no i'm not gonna do
that i'm not gonna do that they won't
even put up the 200 a month
okay well like i said it depends right i
mean do you want to look like that more
than you want anything else right that's
what this girl does
that's what she does
and then she goes to the gym probably a
[ __ ] total of about four hours a week
which is probably two two hour sessions
and for somebody like me that's nothing
but for other people that's like
well other people that have like well
because other people have other
obligations like they have jobs and kids
and families and [ __ ] like that and that
seems like a big
ask which i get well no i get that yeah
i mean it is a big ask we do that at the
club
yeah right but like our life is not like
we don't have any kids right um you know
we don't have like any other obligations
really
like you're retired and i'm freelance
so to a large degree
you know we're kind of like our own
people we can kind of like do what we
want when we want like i said not
sometimes because i still have work i
had to do but
right um you know what i mean but
if that's your
honestly and the thing about it is
instagram models like that that's kind
of like their source of income too
but so it behooves them to
maintain that level so they actually
kind of get paid to do that
it's a little bit of a privilege in a
way well no she doesn't make money from
that i don't think but that's the before
and after um and she was she hasn't been
like that forever
she does probably make money
yeah but i was going to say you think
she doesn't make money from that then um
she probably makes money now i don't
know where you've been she wasn't but
she wasn't making money on that when she
started
you know i don't even think she's a
trainer
most likely she's got a rich boyfriend
that's probably
what it is now i mean you can make quite
a bit of money doing
that like just being a social media
influencer but
i will say that there is a lot of
work involved in that yeah not only just
like being if you're a fitness model you
have to obviously like maintain your
fitness and stuff but you also have to
maintain your social media presence in
the sense that oh you have to live
stream oh you have to like have your
best photos oh you have to like [ __ ]
um keep up with all the
uh with all the [ __ ] it's just kind of
like it's it's a job
uh in and of itself
it's a lot of work and like i said it's
i didn't really realize this until i
started doing
like uh this show and like the blog that
has to do with an instagram account and
[ __ ] like that and thinking about doing
other stuff that's related to it you
really have to hit the [ __ ] hard
all the time or you're not gonna make
any money on it yeah so it's just kind
of like if you want to make some money
on one thing that you're doing like i'm
a fitness model you have to hit that
[ __ ] 24 [ __ ] seven yeah you have
to hit it all the [ __ ] time
so i love it because
it's the end of ifbb pro bodybuilding
that's all [ __ ] like a thing of the
past
muscle beach and all that's a thing of
the past
they just go to the gym and take
pictures of themselves and do stuff and
they can make money on their own they
don't have to worry about judges
it's just if the crowd likes them
then they get success and it's a lot
better
if you went back and look at the female
bodybuilders
that ifbb
pro judges were selecting they didn't
look good
yeah they were extreme but they didn't
look good
let the people decide not those judges
and there you can just be freelance
you know i think it's great
it's the future
holy parish of doom says expressing
emotions that are largely inadmissible
or inappropriate on other contexts yeah
i get that
it's just
i don't know
it's just it's funny because okay so
mike cernicky says i'm in california and
moving to orlando just got a job lined
up at the publix can i crash at you guys
please right now
we don't know your stinky ass
show up here with him stinky ass
you might not be sneaky it might have
been stinky ass feet tom's stinky yeah
but that's my house i'll stink up my own
house farting and [ __ ]
it's not farting do you know what you
smell like since the hormones you smell
like old you know okay you know when
you're a kid and you put like elmer's
glue no it's very specific you put like
elmer's glue on your hand and then you
waited for it to dry and then you peeled
it off yeah and then like you kind of
rolled it up and then it got kind of
gross and dirty chemicals and [ __ ] you
kind of smell like the old dirty rolled
up
elmer's glue screw yeah
it occurred to me like last night
because you like rolled over
and i was awake like i woke up at like 4
30 because i had to pee and then i came
back to sleep
so he's like rolling around and i was
just kind of like and i smelled it and i
was just kind of like man that smells
just like yeah
when some weirdo would like roll their
glue up in their hand and like it got
dirty and stuff and it smells like dirty
old
glute that's what you said
damn it's not two hours a day
it's more like
two
two hour sessions a week
so it's like two hours yeah he's only
gone three hours no you don't work out
that much
most of it is sitting around eating and
growing
most of
it because i mean that's his story he
just lays around like yeah it's like
being a lion
you [ __ ]
work out
you get a [ __ ] real [ __ ] up feeling
and then you just eat something and lay
around just go try to grow back although
look
that's what tom does all the time
i like that
it's much harder it's much harder when
when you're natural and you're not on
any [ __ ] steroids
if you're on hormones or steroids it's
known it's so much easier you just you
heal up so much faster
and you don't need like a big dose at
small doses you just heal up a lot
faster so you're not sitting around
[ __ ] miserable jenny remembers it
i'd be like in my sleep rolling over
going uh
you still do that what are you talking
about not as bad as it was though
no now you roll around going like i
might kill you i'm gonna kill you yeah
yeah yeah you do that i don't know the
devil's talking to me devil's like i
don't know who you're talking to no no
the devil's talking to me you try to
kill me i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna edge
you so yeah
yeah that's what he does this is why i'm
awake all night i'll kill you he keeps
like rolling he's not gonna kill you i'm
gonna kill you i'm gonna kill you yeah
no
devil's telling me that you did that
last night did it yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it's the devil i'm gonna say it's not as
bad as it used to be because
when me and him first started going out
yeah man out of the depth of the [ __ ]
monkeys were trying to [ __ ] eat holy
crap yeah um when i would stay because i
had my own apartment at that time
so i wasn't over there every night yeah
but when i stayed over it has please
um
you had some issues yeah
like you could not sleep without having
some like really really bad nightmares
yeah and then you'd be like thrashing
around you're like [ __ ] thinking
somebody was killing you and like all
this other kind of [ __ ] and obviously it
would wake me up yeah and you were just
kind of like piles of monkeys monkeys
monkeys yeah
i i was getting attacked by seas of
cappuccin monkeys with just teeth and
[ __ ]
just screaming at me
i mean it's not as bad as it used to be
but you still
talk in your sleep yeah it's a little
creepy yeah
you still
listen to your tablet with your
headphones in which like has the light
because there's like a blue light
on the other side of the thing so i have
to like put the thing over my eyes yeah
so it doesn't keep me awake mary says
steroids are not good now stairs are
real good this is what they told you
steroids are real good
it's one of the best [ __ ] one of the
best [ __ ] um
uh i've done a lot of drugs uh steroids
and [ __ ] hormones are the best
[ __ ] drugs i've ever done if you want
to call them drugs they're not really
drugs
they're they're hormone mimickers
they're high performance [ __ ] hormone
mimickers they're they're some of the
best ones
yeah pretty good you just have to know
how to take them
a lot of guys got killed though back in
the 70s and 80s because they were got so
[ __ ] huge there the human heart is
only about the size of a fist
you start putting on [ __ ] a hundred
pounds 150 pounds of muscle over your
genetic potential your heart can't
support well your heart doesn't know
that like is that 200 pounds of muscle
or 200 pounds of fat are you just like
this big [ __ ] fat person 200 pounds
of fat is easier to supply than 200
pounds that's what i'm saying 20. it's
like even then twice the heart is like
yeah not having it yeah 200 pounds of
muscle
is that's worse 200 pounds of muscle
is worse or it's about a long on par or
400 pounds of fat
it's like that because there's all those
vessels in there to supply it
so [ __ ] up all your heart valves your
heart was not designed to [ __ ] supply
the blood to a body that size
and guys were taking that [ __ ] and they
were getting [ __ ] gigantic
and uh and and they were growing big not
only super big but
fast so you know no metabolism was
designed to grow
no dis metabolism was designed
so a person could grow that quickly in
that size it's just not possible
so but you know there were other guys
so you know that that story got out
there these gigantic [ __ ]
pro bodybuilders they're 200 pounds
overweight in muscle 100 something
pounds of weight muscle and they [ __ ]
got that they got that size in a short
period of time
yeah
those [ __ ] dudes are really punch
pushing the limits of what's [ __ ]
possible
and those were the guys that were
genetically
predispositioned to handle those drugs
the guys that weren't
predispositioned died before before they
even got that big or got hurt before
they got that big
so people thought that well that's what
steroids do no that's not mysterious
dude
steroids are healing
agents
doctors prescribe them to people who get
hurt
and allows you to heal up a lot faster
as long as you're not getting [ __ ]
supernaturally huge
you can do them you just can't get too
much overweight you have to be
reasonable with that [ __ ] you can't be
like big raimi that [ __ ] was an
ifbb pro
he was [ __ ] huge and he's had a [ __ ]
ton of health problems the human body
was not supposed to be that big the
heart isn't
equipped to
to pump that much [ __ ] blood
you know so no it's not the steroids
it's steroids
abuse [ __ ] extreme abuse
hell yeah i'll kill you
but you know you look at other guys you
know
they did it normally
you know and uh [ __ ]
what's his name jacqueline was [ __ ]
strong way up into his 80s and 90s
because of that they got guys in their
70s they look like they're 30.
and that's [ __ ] right it's steroids
but they're using steroids to fight
aging
and they're about my size you don't want
to get much bigger than i am right now
for my height
i could probably put on another 10 15
pounds and be safe about it
and lose another 10 pounds of [ __ ]
fat and be safe i couldn't lose another
10 pounds of fat and be safe though i'd
be [ __ ] sub five percent body fat
it's too it's too risky
you just have to know what it is you
have to understand the limits of human
physiology
well that's what i mean i kind of feel
like the problem arises when people are
trying to be extreme
yeah
right when you get to the extremes yeah
obviously it's not gonna work out yeah
do we think it is tammy says there's no
way i could have spared two hundred
dollars and two hours a day i have my
kids at home with work two jobs that's
what i'm saying 200 a month
that's a lot of money yeah and honestly
like if you have two kids at home that
is like a full-time job in itself so
i get it
i get why people can't do that [ __ ] like
like i said i'm not judging anybody i
don't know anybody else's life it's not
my job to like judge other people's
[ __ ] lives for christ's sake nobody
should
they do but they shouldn't
let me show you [ __ ] something
a dude right there is 73 years old
okay
he's 73
and
based on
based on his bmi index and his [ __ ]
blood chemistry he'll probably live into
his 90s
that is his by a bus unless you get hits
by a bus that is not natural okay
it's anabolic steroids and um hrt
hormone replacement therapy
all right
73
like i said it can't be done but
is that like the only thing you want to
do if that's the only thing you want to
do with your life well that's only a few
hours a day four hours a day
tila says christy brinkley and nicole
murphy eddie sex
both look great my kind of bodies but
both have had surgeries and face fillers
that look natural and well done yeah
anything that is not extreme
it works
you just
i feel like like look if you're in
hollywood
and
your whole uh
you know
paycheck depends on you looking a
certain way
i kind of feel like it would behoove you
to more like go into like getting little
surgeries
when you're younger and then like just
getting a little because if you wait
till you're old
and then get like a really extreme
surgery
it doesn't
uh look the same
yeah it doesn't look as good
but
i kind of feel like they figured that
out though in hollywood because you do
kind of see
people getting
little nips and tucks here and there
over time over time so it doesn't like
you don't really notice so it's not
really like obvious yeah a bad example
would have been uh
[ __ ] um
uh bert reynolds burt reynolds well like
i said reynolds because it seemed like
he let himself get kind of well they did
they did that back then like i kind of
feel like that wasn't a thing where it's
like oh we're gonna get little nips and
tucks here and there when we're young
he waited until he got like kind of
older yeah he wasn't getting rolls and
then he did it all at once and then it
looked like his whole face skin had been
like pulled back and stapled on the back
of his head
which
is not a good look for anything
love you bert i'm just saying although a
couple years after he did that he looked
a little bit better it's just that that
[ __ ] friend it did look really weird
at first that [ __ ] looked [ __ ] fun
and that's because [ __ ] you're how
you're supposed to do it is they start
to get little things in their [ __ ]
30s before they need it
and they're they start to lay the
foundation for it
when they go into their 40s and 50s yeah
little things here and there yeah just
like let's just like pull your little
your chin up and let's like let's make
your little [ __ ] make your cheekbones
higher and like
let's raise your eyebrows and [ __ ] like
that like little things that no one
would notice right and if you do that
the whole time i mean if you can afford
it obviously most of us please can't
but if you can afford it i kind of feel
like that's the way to go you wait till
you already look
old as [ __ ] yeah and then you get
surgery
yeah that's nice guys say that some dude
was doing blood doping saving his own
red blood cell look don't believe
anything these [ __ ] tell you
90 of the fitness industry and about 100
of what hollywood tells you is [ __ ]
lies that's not what they're doing
if you're doing any anabolic steroids
you make a lot of [ __ ] red blood
cells
when my blood tests came back from my
hrt clinics they came back all in
superhuman range when it came for
[ __ ] red blood cell counts they were
like you might want to give some blood
you got a little too much red blood cell
i mean i could probably just go for a
run and run myself to death
because you know i was above
my red blood cell count was above
[ __ ] what an olympic athlete would
have
it would have come back where like nah
they'd be kicking me out of the olympics
or pro sports saying hi you're you're
you're jacked
no human has blood looks like that
so a lot of times
these people will make up these weird
well i'm [ __ ] saving my blood for
later no they're doing steroids there's
all kinds of steroids that do different
things
like when straw
and anafar
weird [ __ ] like injectable dianaball
and then there's hrt which is looking
just testosterone which testosterone is
[ __ ] great one of the best ones
and then there's hgh or well hghs is
getting going connie out but then
there's hcg which is human growth
human
[ __ ] well human human
colonia i forgot what it's called but it
was something that they used to give me
and it's the kind of
it's a pituitary gland stimulant it
keeps all your glands running
taking that
um i lost all heartburn i'd be able to
digest everything like i was a kid again
i had terrible heartburn still i went on
hcg
after that i could eat spicy food or
whatever and never have any acid reflux
or heartburn
it's because all your dim
digestive enzymes are all now flowing
there's nothing really wrong with your
body as it ages it's just that the
hormonal signaling isn't as good so you
want to [ __ ] start
putting things in your body that cause
the hormones to [ __ ]
flow and allow [ __ ] biological
processes to happen normally
it's just like teeth if your teeth fall
out you can't chew so you put false
teeth in so you can chew it's the same
thing with hormones your hormones aren't
being produced you put artificial
hormones in there and all of a sudden
everything works again that's all it is
it's not magic it's science
sorry i love this john smith says
my grandfather is still alive at the age
of 106. yeah
at 92 he remarried yeah and at his
wedding he spoke of his new bride and
upcoming nuptials don't worry she won't
die a virgin
that's funny
she won't die virgin hurt tyler the guy
says your grandpa is a damn legend yeah
how old was his wife that's [ __ ]
amazing yeah i don't know he didn't say
92 that that's that's something that's
um
i kind of think about that it's like
it's weird because
like i said i'm 49 which
seems old but
then i think about holy crap i could
live like another 30 40 50 years
and then i get tired
is that bad no i'm not saying that's
wrong i'm just kind of like really i
could live another 50 year ah
that just makes me tired it makes me
want to take a nap thinking about that
holy crap i guess that means i'm old i
don't know
yeah
new bride was in her 60s well she was a
young woman compared to him though
i like it i like it i like it she won't
die a virgin yeah that's pretty rad
your grandpa's 106.
holy crap
i kind of want to live that long but
i kind of don't
i don't know it's a weird thing it
depends on what happens
between now and then right yeah
you know
because
i don't know i kind of feel like a lot
of my life i was like not
i don't know i don't want to say like my
whole youth was like squandered but i do
kind of feel like i didn't really like i
had a childhood i had a youth and stuff
like that but
i kind of feel like i didn't really like
get my [ __ ] together until i was like in
my late 30s everybody feels that way
though so everybody feels that so i kind
of feel like holy [ __ ] i'm already
almost 50.
yeah you know what i mean so
i i really have to like do some [ __ ] now
yeah it's kind of like you know there's
not a lot to do
well i can still do stuff i know how you
feel you just want to like [ __ ] lay
around and do nothing but it's like i i
want to do something that's how she sees
me i want to do some stuff no i mean
just like uh well that's what you said
you don't care about anything okay
i'm like i'm not gonna get into it
just that we we've accomplished a lot
already
you know we've accomplished it already
not enough okay
well there's still [ __ ] i want to do
we'll go do it
i'm not holding you back i'm working on
it i'm not working on it it's not
holding you back well like i said i'm
working on it yeah
what time is it i don't know okay
eight almost eight okay
do any food in this house i have to go
make something yeah i got all kinds of
food down there
are you sober enough to make some or do
you have to order a pizza ain't that
something listen to her
no i'm just like for practical reasons
i'm just asking last time we ordered a
pizza [ __ ] never showed up
i didn't order a pizza i ordered a
sandwich yeah but it was from domino's
okay let's tell that story
yeah so i was like you were not home
i came back and found that [ __ ] and i
was just kind of like well
i might have told the story before but i
was just kind of like okay well i'm just
going to order some dominoes because i
don't feel like cooking and [ __ ] that
so i ordered it wasn't a pizza i ordered
a sandwich
and i think that was it like a sandwich
and maybe a salad
and i ordered it and it was like was it
doordash or it wasn't doordash i think
it was grubhub
so i ordered it from them
and domino's they sent me a message to
like well we don't really have like
delivery people to do this [ __ ] so it
might take a little bit longer and i was
just kind of like okay well take
the time you need whatever
so it's just like just bring my [ __ ]
food just do it so then like an hour or
two later i'm just kind of like is this
food coming or what and then like i
got back with them and they were just
like yeah we don't know what happened
with that and i was like look i think
that the food is not coming
so
what did we end up doing i think we
cancelled it out i cancelled it and then
we went to the chinese restaurant or we
were yeah we were gonna go out yeah and
then we went outside to go to the
chinese restaurant i found a [ __ ] and we
found the domino's food on the doorstep
covered in ants and it was covered in
ants yeah
they just left it there left it
i don't know how long it had been there
it was like it was a sandwich yeah it
was like a it was like a sub and like a
salad yeah
um the salad was okay because it was
like sealed yeah but the sandwich was uh
not edible because it had a bunch of
ants in it but it's like nobody they
didn't call me they didn't text me
they didn't do anything say hey your
food's like on your doorstep they didn't
do anything all right we'll see you t
bye
t's leaving so it was that yeah and i
was just kind of like so um
so from then i've been like really
reluctant like even though domino's is
like right there it's like a mile away
like not even a mile away i'd rather
order from the chinese restaurant
yeah but you gotta go get it i'll go get
it oh they don't have a they'll go again
they don't have that i'll go get it
if you order it i'll go get it i'll go
get it and i'll pay for it
seriously yeah oh my god go ahead and
shut it down
[Laughter]
i'll go get red we're gonna we're gonna
order chinese food i guess
well like i said
i'm not i'm not casting aspersions on
dominoes as a whole i'm just saying the
dominoes that is like a mile away from
us
i was not happy about that situation and
like like i will like they send me
coupons and stuff afterward but i'm like
i don't know if i would order from you
now you're just gonna like leave the
[ __ ] on my doorstep and like not tell me
that it's there
i thought that you
weren't bringing it and then
i went out to get other food and then i
found it and that it like there were
ants in it so
i don't know how long it had been there
but yeah good job so that was that whole
situation
all right uh what are we talking about
now okay so tom has uh [ __ ] off
and so i guess we're gonna get some
chinese food how long
three hours okay that's fair enough
all right so
have a good friday night you guys
um we will be back
sunday afternoon
we'll be talking about that burt
reynolds movie that i mentioned earlier
balloon
maybe some
underage action going on maybe
i don't well not underage but
kind of creepy just saying so there's
that kind of going on so we're going to
talk about that on sunday but thanks
everybody for dropping by
thank you for
super chats and we will see you guys on
sunday afternoon
good night you guys